Nein, nein. So, ihr hört Fritz, dem Blue Moon bzw. heute mit dem erweiterten Titel. Es handelt sich um Chaos Radio, bevor Tim schon wieder so guckt, als hätte ich was Falsches gesagt. Wir sind zu mehreren, unter anderem vom Chaos Computer Club anwesend, der Harald, der Tim und der Frank und meine Person Max von Malodki. Wir richten uns hier noch so ein bisschen ein. Deswegen muss ich jetzt noch so ein paar Anweisungen geben. Unter anderem musst du dein Mikrofon da vorne selber aufmachen, damit man dich hört. Das ist da unten auf dieser riesigen Konsole. Es gibt nur vier Schalter. Da siehst du eins, da steht MIG SPR oder so drauf. Siehst du das? Ja, mach mal alle on. Mach mal alle vier on.
Zipp doch mal auf alles rum.
Nee, das sind wir noch nicht.
Jetzt bin ich zu hören. Jetzt waren wir, das war der vermutlich letzte. Ich probier das noch mal andersrum. Genau, das ist der ganz rechte Seite.
Ach, Technik wird hier direkt erfahren. Sowas passiert auch nur beim Chaos Radio.
Genau, die wird sehr erfahren. Zum Beispiel haben wir gerade mal wieder eingeschränkt das Internet.
Da fühlt sich der Chaos Radio-Mensch ja sofort irgendwie entmannt, oder?
Ja, es ist... ach, ich weiß gar nicht.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt gar keine Musik oder wie?
Doch, doch. Naja, ich teste gerade mal. Aber auf jeden Fall sind wir diesmal hinter der Firewall. Und das heißt, jetzt müssen wir erst mal wieder mit gesperrten Ports kämpfen und so.
Also, ihr merkt schon große Sicherheit hier auch beim RBB insgesamt.
Super Sicherheit.
Natürlich, Tim ist jetzt auch irgendwie beschnitten, weil jetzt hat er halt nur die 40 GB auf seinem iPod an Musik. Und das ist halt einfach zu wenig für drei Stunden. Gut, Thema heute Abend ist natürlich eigentlich so ein bisschen zweigeteilt. Es geht grundsätzlich um Spam. Das haben wir heute auch schon mal gesagt bei den Radio Fritzen am Nachmittag. Das heißt, die unerwünschte E-Mail, die ihr in eurem Briefkasten habt. Aber vorneweg möchten wir eine Sache noch kurz abhandeln, denn es hat ja heute wirklich den großen Hype gegeben oder die letzten Tage, könnte man so sagen.
Ja, wir sind ein bisschen überrascht worden von der Reaktion sowohl der Presse als auch der Leute, die uns dann gemailt haben, daraufhin. Es geht um das Urheberrecht und es geht vor allem um die Nutzung von Tauschbörsen und es geht darum, dass die FP, also das ist der Zusammenschluss der Plattenindustrie, quasi der Musikindustrie, die angekündigt haben, dass sie einen großen Schlag gegen die Nutzer von Tauschbörsen, von Musiktauschbörsen, von Peer-to-Peer-Netzen fahren werden. Das heißt, wir wollen jetzt Leute wirklich strafrechtlich und auch zivilrechtlich belangen.
Das heißt, die wollen doch erst mal, wer oder was diese IFPI überhaupt ist.
Das ist halt eine wunderschöne Frau.
Das ist der Zusammenschluss, das heißt der Industrieverband der pornografischen Industrie oder sowas.
Industrieverband der pornografischen Industrie. Die haben doch jetzt auch diese Porno-Line rausgebracht, oder?
Leute, wir wollten doch erst aufdrehen im Laufe des Abends, oder? Wir wollten am Anfang doch ganz klar und verständlich bleiben.
Die haben die letzte Woche eine große PR-Kampagne gemacht, wo sie gesagt haben, wir bringen euch jetzt alle in den Knast. Alle, ihr verdammten Musikraubkopierer, ihr seid elendige Verbrecher und wir sperren euch jetzt alle ein.
Genau, das ist dann so, was man in Deutschland immer wir streben amerikanische Verhältnisse an nennen würde.
Und daraufhin hat der CTC gesagt, das geht jetzt doch ein bisschen weit irgendwie, wir müssen da jetzt mal was tun. Und haben eigentlich genauso zum Gegenschlag ausgeholt und genauso mit den gleichen Methoden, nämlich sehr plakativ, haben wir so ein paar Banner gemacht, wo wir gesagt haben, also pass mal auf, wir sind keine Terroristen und irgendwie Kopien ist ja okay, es geht hier um Kulturgut. Und entspannt euch mal ein bisschen. Und das Presseecho auf diese Veröffentlichung war heute wirklich immens. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Artikel wir überall hatten. Es kamen irgendwie ganz viele, viele Leute haben uns geschrieben, es haben uns Leute auch noch selbstgemachte Banner geschickt. Und das könnt ihr auch gerne noch weiter tun. Da sind wir irgendwie sehr dankbar drüber. Die bauen wir dann auch sofort auf die Seite ein, wenn die cool sind. Und ja, wir hoffen, dass damit jetzt ein bisschen die Diskussion in Gang kommt. Wir haben ja gerade mit dem Paul ja auch schon rausgehend noch ein bisschen diskutiert dazu. Und das Thema ist wirklich sehr kompliziert. Also es lässt sich halt nicht so auf zwei, drei Banner reduzieren. Und wir haben schon Sendungen zu dem Thema gehabt. Wir müssen, glaube ich, aber in Zukunft noch ein bisschen mehr machen. Und überlegen uns vielleicht für die nächste Sendung, ob wir da was drüber machen.
Ja, also wäre für den heutigen Abend natürlich ein bisschen über das Knie gebrochen und vertan, wenn man das jetzt einfach so ad hoc stemmen würde.
Ja, also wir brauchen da schon Leute, mit denen wir auch wirklich gut diskutieren können. Wir brauchen einen Juristen, der uns ein bisschen sagen kann, wo das mit dem Urheberrecht alles herkommt, welche Möglichkeiten der Verfolgung die Musikindustrie überhaupt hat, was büten wir als Tauschbörsen?
Es geht ja auch nicht so sehr ums Urheberrecht, sondern vielmehr ums Verwertungsrecht, denke ich mal, an der Stelle.
Naja, das ist ja basiert ja schon auch auf dem Urheberrecht, also dass einfach der Urheber darüber verfügen kann, was denn mit den Sachen passiert ist, auch derjenige, der Preise festlegt dafür, was er glaubt, dass die Leute dafür zahlen sollten. Und es hat ja alles ein bisschen damit zu tun, wir sagen ja auch, dass die CD-Preise zu hoch sind. Das ist natürlich auch erstmal eine Sache, die wir so sagen. Was vielleicht eher damit zu tun hat, dass die Leute merken, wie wenig von dem Geld, was so eine CD kostet, 15, 20 Euro, wie viel davon eigentlich bei den Künstlern ankommt. Und dass die Leute jetzt starten, das zu durchschauen und merken, dass das vielleicht nicht so rechtfertigt ist. Und deswegen da eher weniger Hemmungen haben, auch diese Tauschbörsen zu benutzen. Ich weiß es nicht, das ist so ein bisschen Diskussion. Da ist aber eigentlich eine eigene Sendung für angesagt. Das können wir heute Abend jetzt auf die Kurze nicht besprechen.
Also ein bisschen Geduld haben, das Thema wird sicherlich in einem Monat nicht an Brisanz verloren haben. Da wird man umso mehr, weil dann auch die 0815-Johnnies endlich drauf kommen, wie wichtig das ist, ihre Messer gewetzt haben und da kann man sich umso besser darüber unterhalten. Thema deswegen heute Abend, eines der Themen, was sich im Bereich Multimedia wirklich etabliert hat, über Jahrtausende fast, nämlich Spam. Spam, also diese ekligen E-Mails, die wir immer wahrscheinlich mittlerweile alle im Briefkasten haben, elektronischerweise. Also bei mir ist es so nur mal als Beispiel für den heutigen Abend. Auf meiner Mail-Adresse beim rbb-online.de, also mvm.rbb-online.de, kommt so viel Spam an, dass ich pro Tag ungefähr 150 E-Mails habe. Davon sind zwei tatsächlich nicht Spam. Mehr ist da nicht drin. Also ich habe noch nie mehr als zwei Mails gehabt. Die Rate ist ungefähr so, der Rest, da geht es um Penisverlängerungen und ähnliches. Und darum soll es heute Abend gehen, auch um die technischen Möglichkeiten. Um Penisverlängerungen?
Warum soll es heute gehen?
Ich sage euch, ich habe da Erkenntnisse gewonnen. Also ich komme nicht mehr durch die Tür, vor Glück. Ja, dann lass uns doch einfach mal umsteigen, umsatteln und in das Thema einleiten. Und dann können wir auch direkt mit der Diskussion beginnen. Ich habe mir auch mal gedacht für heute, weil wir haben ja eine wunderbare neue Internetseite und ein ganz tolles Board, dass wir das auch mal mitbenutzen. Guck nicht so skeptisch, du hast vorhin schon zu der Musik getanzt. Ich darf mir heute alles erlauben.
Ich gucke überhaupt nicht skeptisch. Du legst mir da schon wieder was in den Mund. Du hast recht.
Ich kenne doch deine Stirnfalte.
Du hast recht.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt mal vielleicht... Frank, machst du so einen kleinen Thread auf oder so?
Ja, ich probiere mal erstmal irgendwie meine Web-Mail zu kriegen, weil ihr könnt uns ja noch Mail schicken an die Sendung. Das ist an 90.chaosradio.ccc.de, also 90.chaosradio.ccc.de. Wenn ihr Sachen zum Thema habt, zum Thema Spam, bitte keinen Spam schicken. Den kriegen wir echt genug auf diesen Adressen.
Gut, 0331 77 97 110 ist auf jeden Fall schon mal die Hotline, wenn ihr aus dem Kalten und ohne jetzt warm geworden zu sein durch die Diskussion schon mal selber dazu beitragen möchtet, zum Thema Spam, egal von welcher Seite, ob ihr vielleicht selber Fragen habt, wie ihr mit Spam umgehen sollt, was man da tun kann oder wenn ihr selber meinetwegen hier irgendeinen Server betreut und selber da wisst, was ihr gegen Spam macht.
Und vor allem, was würdet ihr mit diesem Spammann machen? Stellt euch vor, ihr trefft den mal irgendwo auf einer Party. Was würdet ihr denn mit dem machen?
Gut. Und alles Sachen, die mit Blut zu tun haben, bitte erst nach 23 Uhr. 033 171 97 91 10 ist die Nummer. Wollen wir uns jetzt in Musik noch so ein bisschen ergehen? Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz mit dabei, der Harald, der Tim und der Frank vom CCC und meine Wenigkeit der Max. Hab jetzt mal schnell einen kleinen Thread eingerichtet unter fritz.de. Dann da auf interaktiv die Boards klicken und euch zum Fritz-Board durchklicken. Dann findet ihr das, könnt da rein posten, wenn ihr schriftlich was zum Thema Spam loswerden wollt. Wir wollen auch regelmäßig vorlesen, aber vornehmlich könnt ihr natürlich anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Wir haben nur gerade festgestellt, dass wir natürlich wieder einfach nur Spam gesagt haben und gar nicht gesagt haben, was Spam überhaupt ist. Da hört es nämlich bei vielen schon auf.
Ja, also bei Spam handelt es sich um unerwünschte Werbe E-Mail, was auch oft im englischen Sprachgebrauch mit dem Sprachkürzel UCE schrägstrich UBE abgekürzt, also Unsolicited Commercial E-Mail, Unsolicited Business E-Mail. Es geht also einfach um Werbung, die versendet wird.
Bulk E-Mail auch?
Bulk E-Mail, ja eben auch. Unerwünschte E-Mail, die zumeist irgendwelche Werbeinhalte oder aber auch Bezugsinhalte hat und einen zu irgendetwas bringen soll. Bevor man aber zu Spam kommt, sollte man vielleicht noch mal ein Stückchen weiter ausholen und über E-Mail im Allgemeinen reden. E-Mail ist ja der älteste Dienst im Internet, ist eigentlich noch entstanden, bevor das Internet selbst entstanden ist. Es gab also Netze vor dem Internet, in denen es nur die Möglichkeit zum E-Mail-Austausch gab. Da gibt es das Fido-Netz, das Z-Netz und Ähnliches.
Und das Usenet natürlich.
Und das Usenet natürlich, klar, das dann in das Internet übergegangen ist. Und das funktioniert relativ ähnlich wie das Postsystem. Es gibt keinerlei Verifikationen. Wenn ich auf ein Kuvert draufschreibe, ich bin, was weiß ich, Helmut Kohl, dann steht das eben auf diesem Kuvert drauf und dann kann ich das absenden.
Du bist das?
Ja, und es gibt eben einfach keine Überprüfungsmechanismen. Das war am Anfang ein akademisches Netz oder ein Hobbyisten-Netz. Und das hat auf Vertrauensbasis funktioniert. Und dann mit der zunehmenden Kommerzialisierung des Internets kam eben auch die Werbung in dieses Medium. Und nachdem das Versenden einer E-Mail eben de facto kein Geld kostet, freuen sich da die Werbeunternehmen ganz ungemein.
Genau, und es gibt so tolle Sachen, wie da wird halt für irgendwie harte Pornografie geworben. So das kriegen auch irgendwie Kinder in ihre E-Mail-Adressen. Das ist halt so gar nicht so lustig. Es gibt irgendwie Spam für irgendwelche super peinlichen Medikamente oder für Software. Da wird irgendwie für Geld und Glücksspiele geworben. Da werden irgendwelche komischen Kontaktforen angepriesen. Es gibt... Da werden CDs voller einer Million E-Mail-Adressen zum Vollspam angeboten, auch sehr dreist. Es gibt irgendwelche E-Mails, die versuchen, die Leute dazu aufzufordern, irgendwo in irgendwelchen Webseiten ihre Kreditkarten-Nummern einzugeben oder ihre PayPal-Accounts oder eBay-Accounts, damit die dann irgendwie missbraucht werden können. Es versuchen sogar irgendwelche Banken, irgendwelche erdachten Banken, die es gar nicht gibt, oder irgendwelche Kreditinstitute, versuchen irgendwie für sich Werbung zu machen, dass Leute da Geld anlegen, da ist auch sehr bekannt dieser nigerianische Spam, wo Leute irgendwie zu irgendwelchen dubiosen Geschäften überredet werden, wo sie vorab Geld überweisen sollen. Und es ist unglaublich, dass das Leute auch machen. Also da gibt es so ein paar Fälle, wo Leute wirklich da gut, glaube ich, irgendwie Tausende von Dollars oder Euros hinüberwiesen haben und sich dann wundern, dass da irgendwie nichts mehr kam.
Nicht nur das, das sind sogar schon Leute umgekommen, ernsthaft. Also es gibt in den USA mittlerweile tatsächlich eine nigerianische, eine Task Force in der Polizei, die sich nur mit dem nigerianischen Scam, also es geht ja um Betrug in dem Fall nicht nur um Spam, sondern um Scam, befasst. Und das sind tatsächlich Leute umgekommen, die also dann in diese Länder gereist haben und versucht haben irgendwie ihrem Geld wieder nachzugehen.
Unglaublich. Ja und letztendlich natürlich auch...
Davor, dass es gleich wieder fallen, also da gibt es eine schöne Informationsseite, die hier auch aus Berlin heraus betrieben wird, nämlich nigeria-connection.de, wo diese gesamten Zusammenhänge, speziell diese Nigeria-Geschichte, zusammengetragen sind, nebst vielen Beispielen dieser Briefe, die da mal verschickt werden.
Ja und letztendlich gibt es natürlich auch diese ganzen Viren, Würmer, Trojaner, Dialer, die irgendwie kommen. Das sind dann irgendwelche Read the attached file und dann ist da irgendwie ein Attachment dran und wenn man das ausführt, zack, hat man gleich irgendwie eine komische Software auf seinem Rechner. Das fällt letztendlich auch alles in diese ganze Problematik, nämlich dass die Leute irgendwie Mails aufmachen, irgendwo draufklicken, ohne irgendwie zu wissen, was sie da tun und natürlich auch, weil diese ganze Struktur, diese Mail-Struktur nicht wirklich vertrauenswürdig ist.
Ja, das ist wichtig, dass man das vor allem auseinander hält, weil unter dieser Gesamtklammer Spam bringt man dann die Sachen auch schnell durcheinander. Es gibt also verschiedene Baustellen, an denen das gutgläubige E-Mail-System des Internets ausgehebelt wird und missbraucht wird und dementsprechend braucht man eben auch unterschiedliche Ansätze, um die einzelnen Dinge dann auch zu verhindern. Bei Trickbetrügern ist das natürlich ganz schön schwierig, weil die haben da ja eine hohe kriminelle Energie und von daher werden die uns wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile begleiten. Was allerdings so diese typische Massenbisbämmerung betrifft, gibt es durchaus schon Ansätze, da auch was gegen machen zu können.
Aber letztendlich ist es doch alles die Schuld der User. Weil wenn niemand auf Spam-Mails klicken würde, wenn niemand irgendwo da mal auf Viagra oder in Larger Penis klicken würde, wenn es wirklich niemand tun würde.
Ja, du kannst natürlich auch Handgranaten irgendwie den Leuten nach Hause schicken und wenn sie dann irgendwie den Ring ziehen, ist es ihre eigene Schuld. Aber so würde ich die Sache halt ungern betrachten wollen.
Nee, klar, damit ist es natürlich dann einfach zu sagen, ach die User sind alle schuld, kein Problem, aber ja.
Man muss sich halt darüber bewusst sein, dass Handgranaten in Briefkasten liegen können.
Wenn die durch den Schlitz passen. Ich habe mir gerade Gedanken gemacht. Die sind meistens zu dick.
Die Handgranaten?
Ja, das ist ein Päckchen, das wird dann zum Nachbarn geliefert.
Die erfinden neue.
Die erfinden welche, die genauso breit sind wie dein Briefkasten.
Briefkasten, Handgranaten. Das ist aber ein anderes Chaosradio.
Briefbomben sind ja nicht wirklich was Neues.
Ja, das ist richtig. Gut, wenn ihr zum Thema mitreden möchtet, also zum Thema Spam, diesen unerwünschten E-Mails, die ihr bestimmt schon bekommen habt, dann ruft an, vielleicht auch einfach nur, um die bescheuertsten Beispiele vorzutragen, die jemals bei euch gelandet sind.
Und was uns natürlich besonders interessieren würde, falls also irgendjemand von euch offen im administratorischen Bereich vorzüglich so bei Internet Service Providern oder auch für eure eigene Domänen jemand also viel Erfahrung gesammelt hat mit Spam-Bekämpfungsmaßnahmen, würden wir darüber auch sehr gerne hören, was bei euch gut funktioniert, was ihr so für Tricks anwendet oder Gegenmaßnahmen schon angewandt habt und was eben geklappt hat und was nicht geklappt hat.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz unsere Mail-Adresse. Das ist die 90atchaosradio.ccc.de Da hat zum Beispiel auch der Rudolf geschrieben und hat uns darauf hingewiesen, dass GMX unseren Chaosradio-Update, also unseren Chaosradio-Ticker, den wir mal vor der Sendung rausschicken, um euch an heute zu erinnern, das filtern die einfach mal als Spam weg. Ihr Pisser.
Das war natürlich keine Beleidigung. Da ging es grundsätzlich um die Fähigkeit ruinieren zu können, die jetzt hier erwähnt werden sollte.
Das ist einfach mal eine Frechheit.
Weißt du, Geier, ob das wirklich so... Das war sicherlich keine Absicht. Das zeigt ein großes Problem auf. Diese ganzen Bekämpfungsmaßnahmen gehen natürlich auch in die falsche Richtung. Am Anfang hatten wir auch bei uns, denke ich, mal kollektiv so die Meinung, wieso Spam, das muss man irgendwie beim Klienten, also bei demjenigen, der es letztendlich ins Empfängt rausfiltern, weil ist ja nicht so viel und das auf dem Server zu installieren, birgt die Gefahr, dass eben legitime Mails rausgefiltert werden. Allerdings ist das Spam-Aufkommen mittlerweile dermaßen hoch, dass es also schon fast niemandem mehr zuzumuten ist, insbesondere weniger erfahrenen End-Usern.
Ja, vor allem auch nicht Dial-Up-Usern. Also das Problem ist ja auch, wenn ich per Modem oder per E-Mail hole, dann zahle ich ja wirklich für jede Mail. Also alles dauert, ja es hat nicht jeder einen Flat-Drag. Dann breiten Bedarf. So wenn ich halt irgendwie eine zeitbasierte Abrechnung habe, wenn ich mich irgendwo einwähle und ich kriege da irgendwie 200 Mails, so dann kann es halt schon mal sein, dass das irgendwie eine Telefon-Einheit ist oder so, die da bei drauf geht.
Insbesondere dann, wenn irgendein lästiges Attachment dabei ist, von dem ich dann feststelle, dass es nur ein Dialer ist, den ich dann auch noch mit runtergeladen habe.
Ja, die ganzen Viren, die sind gar nicht so klein. Also ich hatte da auch eine Zeit lang meine Mail auf einem ziemlich teuren Server und das hat mich richtig Geld gekostet, diesen ganzen Scheiß überhaupt zu übertragen.
Ja, weil die schlampig programmiert sind. Die könnten ja auch kleiner sein.
Die Viren? Du meinst, wir sollten darüber reden, wie man Viren optimieren kann, damit sie nicht so viel Bandbreite verbrauchen?
Ja, richtig.
Es ist auch eine Art und Weise, damit umzugehen.
Man muss sich das dann eben vorstellen bei der Zahl der Leute, die eben E-Mail anwenden, wenn man das hochrechnet, ja, das ist jetzt für einen vielleicht mal eine Telefon-Einheit, aber eben für die Millionen von E-Mail-Accounts, die es gibt und für die Milliarden von E-Mails, die versendet werden, wenn man das hochrechnet.
Was hat AOL gesagt? 50% Spam oder sowas mittlerweile?
Über.
Also ist ja jedenfalls in einer Größenordnung. Also das ist ein ernstzunehmendes Problem.
50%? Naja, wir haben nochmal einen Provider befragt, den wir jetzt hier so beim Namen nicht nennen wollen, aber schon einer, der auch schon länger im Business ist. Und die haben so in etwa den Durchlauf von 75% aller E-Mails, die überhaupt ankommen, sind Spam. 5% aller E-Mails sind Viren und Würmer, also diese typischen Programmen-Attachments, meistens dann halt für Windows oder eigentlich fast nur für Windows.
Und nur in einem Prozent sind interessante Firmengeheimnisse.
20% sind halt, naja, interessante Firmengeheimnisse liegen ja so auf dem Webbrom, obwohl man ja keine E-Mails hat.
Da muss nur Google nach vertraulichem BDF.
Diesen Zahlen muss man eben auch immer vorsichtig sein. Das kommt immer sehr auf die technischen Details an, wie die erfasst wurden und was man jetzt wie wo gezählt hat und so weiter.
Ja, aber es zeigt eine Richtung an. Sie meinten auch, sie hätten ungefähr 90% Erfolg beim Rausfiltern von Spam. Wie sie das jetzt sozusagen ermittelt haben, ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, aber wahrscheinlich auf Basis eigener Erfahrungen.
Gut, ihr könnt natürlich auch abgesehen vom Mails schreiben, telefonisch teilnehmen, 0331 77 97 110 und bei uns ins Board schreiben, unter fritz.de auf interaktiv und boards und fritz, dann klicken und da findet ihr den Thread zum Thema Spam. Da könnt ihr euch auch verewigen, wie das der Sascha da getan hat, der uns allerdings nur grüßt. Danke Sascha. Ob das schon Spam ist, das natürlich die Frage. Der Wolfgang ist am Telefon. Hey Wolfgang.
Also ich hatte bis vor einem Jahr oder so, ich hab Z-Raid, muss ich dazu sagen. Und wenn ich da am Wochenende mal meinen Rechner angelassen habe, hatte ich auch so 150 so eine kumpchen Spams drinne. Und dann hab ich mich mal beigemacht, diese kumpchen Anti-Spam-Programme da durchzuforsten. Und die kosten mir auch irgendwie alle Geld. Da dachte ich mir, jetzt muss man doch irgendwie diesen Nachrichtendienst abschalten können. Hab ich das gefunden und gesucht und gefunden auf meinem Rechner. Hab diesen Nachrichtendienst einfach abgeschaltet. Das ist einfach nur ein kleines Siegchen, was man hintermachen muss in der Windows Nachrichtendienst. Und seit ungefähr einem Jahr hab ich keine Anti-Spam mehr. Wenn das nicht ein Erfolg ist.
Ich denke, dass das irgendwo ein Missverständnis ist, worüber wir hier gerade reden. Du sprichst über solche Pop-Abmeldungen, die kommen bei dir.
Nee, die ganz normalen Spam, die über Nachrichtendienst reinkommen.
Ja eben, die über Nachrichtendienst. Das ist eine andere Funktion. Wir sprechen hier von E-Mail-Spam in der Sendung. Es gibt durchaus auch noch andere Möglichkeiten, wie es denen ermöglicht wird, unerwünschte Botschaften dir auf deinem Rechner anzuzeigen. Aber für E-Mail-Spam gibt es keine so eindeutige Lösung. Dass die Software zum Filtern von Spam immer Geld kostet, ist generell auch so nicht richtig. Es gibt auch im Bereich der freien Software durchaus einige Projekte, die unterschiedliche technische Ansätze verfolgen, um Spam-E-Mails eben herauszufiltern. Da werden wir uns später noch damit beschäftigen, was es denn dafür technische Ansätze gibt.
Ich hab das bei meinem bekannten Freundeskreis erzählt. Die hatten ja auch dieselben Probleme, ständig diese ganzen Spams wegklicken mussten. Der Briefkasten war voll gewesen. Die haben genau dasselbe gemacht. Und auch seitdem haben sie Ruhe. Einfach nur die Nachrichten ausgeschaltet. Die kriegen jetzt wirklich nur noch die E-Mails, die sie haben wollen. Und dann sind diese ganzen Spams weg.
Alles klar.
Es scheint zu funktionieren. Was direkt an deine Adresse geschickt wird, ist natürlich schwierig, aber da hab ich auch keine mehr. Und der Rechner läuft bei mir 24 Stunden am Tag.
Du glücklich, ja. Danke für den Anruf, Wolfgang.
Ja, tschüss, tschüss, tschau.
Da lag natürlich noch schon eine kleine Verwechslung vor, um das nochmal klar zu machen. Also dieser Windows-Nachrichtendienst, das war halt so eine offensichtliche Lücke bei Windows. Der war halt serienmäßig offen. Der war halt für mal wieder für was Gutes gedacht, dass man nämlich so Echtzeitkommunikation im Windows-Lahn machen kann. Mit der einer schickt dem anderen eine Nachricht, ohne dass man jetzt gleich Instant-Messenger benutzen muss. Das war halt offen und so offen, dass eben, ja, Companies das ausgenutzt haben, sozusagen den Leuten direkt die Fenster auf dem Bildschirm geöffnet haben. AOL hat dann irgendwann mal ein Update für ihre Zugangssoftware rausgebracht und das Installieren dieses Updates hat dann auch automatisch diesen Dienst zugemacht, weil sie einfach keine Lust hatten, da auf Microsoft zu warten. Und soweit ich weiß, hat aber Microsoft das mittlerweile auch behoben. Aber was weiß ich schon, was denn los?
Zwei Sachen, die bei uns in Bord reingekommen sind, zum einen der Kommentar zum GMX-Spam-Filter, was ich ganz lustig finde, dass das ganz normal sei, dass der zwischendurch schreibt Schuppi immer mal den CCC-Ticker bzw. auch mal eBay-Mails rausfiltert. Lustig allerdings ist eine Bemerkung, dass auch schon mal der eigene GMX-Newsletter rausgefiltert worden sei, von dem GMX-eigenen Spam-Filter. Ja, da wird wahrscheinlich einer noch einen Sack bekommen haben, dass er da falsche Wörter reingeschrieben hat. Aber er sagt, das wäre eine Konfigurationsfrage. Und dann was Interessantes von Godfather. Er schreibt, dass er einen E-Mail-Account hat hier bei einer Spielezeitschrift, in dem Fall bei gamestar.de, da Premium-Member ist und da sein E-Mail-Account habe und dass er seit eineinhalb Jahren keinen einzigen Spam bekommen habe. Woran liegt denn das, dass man irgendwie mit bestimmten E-Mail-Accounts Tausende bekommt und mit anderen vielleicht keinen?
Das kommt wohl darauf an, inwiefern die E-Mail-Adresse bekannt ist irgendwo. Wenn ich jetzt eine E-Mail-Adresse habe und niemand von der Existenz dieser E-Mail-Adresse weiß, dann werde ich auch mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit nie Spam bekommen an diese E-Mail-Adresse. Wenn jetzt die aber natürlich überall auftaucht und die überall im Web zu finden ist und man die bei allen möglichen Webseiten angebt, wo man sich registriert, dann ist natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass die E-Mail-Adresse irgendwann früher oder später in einer der Datenbanken landet, die von diesen Werbeversendern gebraucht werden.
Viele E-Mail-Adressen werden auch nicht unbedingt gesammelt, sondern einfach erraten. Also fast an alle Domains gehen halt so standardmäßig alle bekannten Vornamen, Nachnamen, Abkürzungen, Nicknames, also im Prinzip von jeder bekannten E-Mail-Adresse, was vor dem Ad steht. Dasselbe wird dann sozusagen an jede beliebige andere Domain auch nochmal davor gehängt, weil sie einfach davon ausgehen, dass es irgendwie ein Tim-Ad und ein Max-Ad, das gibt es halt auch fast unter jeder Domain. Und wenn nicht, naja, Pech gehabt, ist es auch wieder nur eine Mail, die in Orkus zugegeben wird.
Es gibt dann tatsächlich eben Leute, die, ja, Firmen, wie auch immer, Geschäftsleute, wie weiß man das, für Menschen sind, die versuchen eben einfach nur gültige E-Mail-Adressen herauszufinden, durch einfach ausprobieren. Ich habe mal so ein bisschen meine persönlichen Statistiken auf meinem E-Mail-Server angeguckt. Und das ist also so, dass ich 48.000 E-Mails in einem Monat bekomme und zusätzlich dazu tatsächlich 80.000 Anfragen an ungültige Adressen. Das sind hier nahezu das Doppelte von dem, was ich tatsächlich an E-Mails bekomme, sind noch mal Anfragen an Adressen, die gar nicht existieren, wo jemand nur versucht herauszufinden, was das denn für ihn hat.
80.000. Da kann man auch froh sein, wenn man nur irgendwie 150 Adressen kommt, die bei dem ankommen.
Das scheint hier ein generelles Thema zu sein, weil viele diese bei uns im Board jetzt gerade, weil viele diese Art von Mail-Accounts haben, bei so Free-Mail-Services, sowas wie Hotmail oder hier GMX wird jetzt gerade wieder genannt. Da sagt Flo, ich hab hier meine GMX-Felder mittlerweile ausgestellt, weil der seinerzeit sogar die Bestellbestätigung von meinem Notebook ausgefiltert hat. Schön.
Boah, Fritz hat ja eine neue Homepage.
Mal sehen, wann er sie verreißt. Gut, jedenfalls die Frage serverseitige Filter. Das wäre ja schön, wenn, also ich stelle mir das immer so vor, ich kriege halt irgendwie tausende von Mails und denke, es muss doch einen intelligenten Filter geben, der serverseitig den ganzen Scheiß schon mal rausfiltert, sodass ich mich damit überhaupt nicht befassen muss. Wo liegt denn das Risiko?
Na das Problem mit solchen Filtern ist eben, dass die auf den Inhalt der E-Mail gehen. Und man hat da die gleiche Diskussion, die man auch bei Internet-Zensurversuchen hat, wo also schon zu früheren Zeiten mal bei Confuserve zum Beispiel alles gefiltert wurde, wo das Wort Breast oder so drin vorkommt. Und dann hab ich halt die Brustkrebs-Selbsthilfe-Gruppe, die dann ihre E-Mails nicht mehr austauschen kann, weil das verbotene Wort drin auftaucht. Und das ist eben ein Wetttouristen hier von den Betreibern der Filter und den Werbee-Mailern auf der anderen Seite, wo man also versucht dann diese Filter zu umgehen. Dann schreibt man eben Viagra mit 1 statt nem i in dem Wort drin, und dann schon bin ich nicht mehr im Filter drin. Und so geht das dann halt immer eine Stufe höher.
Gerade diese Sprachverwirrung, die ist eigentlich mittlerweile sehr kreativ geworden. Also es gab ja sowas als Lead, was du so kennt aus der Cracker-Szene oder aus Leuten, die irgendwie aus der Demo-Szene, die dann halt auch anfangen Buchstaben, praktisch gegen ähnlich aussehende Zahlen auszutauschen. Ja, die Gamer. Genau, unheimlich Lead. So in die Richtung geht es also, dass dann da wirklich Buchstaben ausgetauscht werden. Das basiert darauf, dass das Auge, das Gehirn, die Sachen den Inhalt wahrnimmt, ohne dass es jetzt genau so geschrieben ist, wie es der Spamtheater erkennen würde.
Also zum Thema Lead, wer das jetzt nicht kennt, Lead, so wie ich es kenne, wäre abgeleitet von Elite, also von Elite und ist das Gegenteil von Lame. Und wird dann geschrieben 1337, das heißt dann L-E-E-T in dieser Sprache. Also das ist dann der Gag dabei. Macht natürlich Spaß, super Code, aber wenn man deswegen dann irgendwelche Spammails hat, weil das irgendwie durchgegangen ist, natürlich trotzdem scheiße. 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer, ihr könnt mitmachen. Aber wir machen glaube ich jetzt erstmal ein Häppchen Nachrichten, bevor wir wieder groß einsteigen in die Diskussion, weil wir haben es kurz nach halb. Matthias Kerkoff ist auch schon auf dem Weg.
Wenn Fritz in Oranienburg, dann 100 2, 6.
Morgen ist es dann erstmal heiter. Ab und zu schieben sich ein paar Wolken vor die Sonne. Ist aber irrelevant. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 16 Grad. Jetzt die Meldungen mit Matthias Kerkoff.
Im Mannesmann-Prozess können alle Angeklagten nach dem bisherigen Stand der Beweisaufnahme mit Freisprüchen rechnen. Das sagte die Vorsitzende Richterin. Es gebe keine Anhaltspunkte für Untreue gegenüber der Mannesmann AG. Bei dem Prozess geht es um die umstrittenen Millionenzahlungen nach der Übernahme durch Vodafone. Als erstes Bundesland führt Bayern die 42-Stunden-Woche im öffentlichen Dienst ein. Für Beamte gilt die längere Arbeitszeit vom 1. September an. Von Mai an werden Angestellte und Arbeiter nur noch dann eingestellt oder befördert, wenn sie 42 Stunden arbeiten. Die Wiedervereinigung Zyperns ist in weite Ferne gerückt. Die Verhandlungen darüber sind gescheitert, teilte ein türkischer Regierungsmitarbeiter mit. Nun soll UN-Generalsekretär Anan über die noch offenen Streitpunkte entscheiden. Sein Vorschlag soll dann der Bevölkerung im griechischen und im türkischen Teil zur Abstimmung vorgelegt werden. Zum Sport in einem Fußball-Länderspiel bezwang soeben Deutschland-Belgi mit 3 zu 0. Und die deutsche Fußballfrauen-Nationalmannschaft hat das Testspiel gegen Italien mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Und der Verkehr, Fritz, wir haben keine aktuellen Meldungen weiter.
Für ein richtig gutes Radiokonzert braucht man richtig gute Musik. Und ein richtig gutes Publikum. Also euch. Das exklusive Radiokonzert im Kolumbier Fritz-Berlin. Aber Karten gibt's nirgendwo zu kaufen, nur zu gewinnen. Also wer live und laut im Radio dabei sein will, diese Woche einfach gut Fritz hören und Karten gewinnen. You're listening to The Streets. Das exklusive Radiokonzert kommenden Sonntag. Ab 20 Uhr live im Kolumbier Fritz-Berlin und im Radio. 3.20 Uhr.
Ihr macht euch echt über mich lustig. Ich sage immer nur Achtung, damit ihr nicht rumbabbelt wie die Großen hier, wie die Kleinen eher gesagt, um euch nicht zu verbabbeln. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz, wir haben es 20 vor 11 und haben damit noch gute fast zweieinhalb Stunden Zeit zu quatschen über das Thema Spam heute Abend. Und zwei Dinge zu meinen war unser Stream gerade dran, weil uns ja auch viele, viele, viele Leute von woanders hören und uns nicht empfangen können, nur in Berlin und Brandenburg über Radio. Das ist aber mittlerweile behoben, so wie wir hoffen zumindest. Zwingst du mir zu?
Der mp3 Stream läuft wieder, da gab es gerade ein Internet Service Provider Problem. Und das hat der Internet Service Provider wohl behoben. Und ich habe jetzt hier auch das Problem, mit der keine Musik auf dem Kanal behoben, weil das ist eine kleine Steckerchen, die die vorhin schon startete.
Eine kleine Steckerchen, sie ist eine kleine Steckerchen, ja. Hast du noch mal ein Sport in mp3 Stream? Bist du so lieb? Ja, mach ich doch gerne. Also wenn ihr das nachlesen wollt, dann könnt ihr auf spritz.de da aufs Board klicken. Ansonsten, den Song hören wir uns gleich an zum Thema Spam, oder? Da lassen wir uns noch ein Momentchen mit Zeit.
Genau, nehmen wir doch mal einen Anrufer rein.
Ja, machen wir das. Am Telefon ist der Björn. Hallo Björn.
Hallo. Und zwar kotzt mich das auch an mit diesen ganzen Werbemails, die man da so bekommt. Und ich hab meine E-Mail-Adresse also mittlerweile dermaßen voll, dass ich keinen Speicher mehr drauf hab. Ich hab das auch mit Absicht voll laufen lassen, dass diese E-Mails, die dann kommen, auch gleich wieder zurückgehen. Ich hab das jetzt ungefähr schon ein halbes Jahr so praktiziert, weil ich einfach, ja wie soll ich sagen, weil ich das einfach nicht eigentlich mittlerweile hasse, E-Mails auch zu schreiben.
Ja, das kann man verstehen, dass da eine richtige Verzweiflung entsteht. Das Problem ist eben nur, wenn du die alle bouncing lässt, wenn dein E-Mail-Account voll ist, dann kannst du halt auch keine E-Mails mehr von deinen Freunden empfangen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Die haben sich auch schon dran gewöhnt.
Du bist sozusagen von dem E-Mail-Verkehr abgeschnitten.
Ja, richtig. Ich hab meine E-Mail-Adresse bei Yahoo! Und ich kann auch irgendwo diese Anbieter verstehen, die sich da nicht wirklich einen Kopf machen darum, wie sie das verbessern können. Ich meine, teilweise haben sie das ja schon gemacht. Aber ich sag mal, solange der Dienst kostenfrei ist, wird das auch immer ein Problem bleiben. Es gibt natürlich auch Anbieter, die für die E-Mail-Adresse Geld nehmen. Das sind aber mittlerweile auch größere Formen, kann man sagen. Tja, es machen schon, aber eher noch weniger. Und solange das eben, wie gesagt, kostenfrei ist, wird das auch so bleiben. Weil intelligente Lösungen wird es da schon geben. Bloß die werden Geld kosten und auch einen entsprechenden Aufwand mit sich bringen. Und das wird auch alles sicherer werden, wenn man beispielsweise Werbung anmelden muss, die in E-Mails verschickt werden. Und wenn es wenigstens noch Werbung wäre, die interessant ist, worauf was hinter steht, dann wäre das ja alles wahrscheinlich auch halb so wild. Aber da das alles nur Quatsch ist, ist es halt Datenschrott. Also einen Haufen Müll, den man eigentlich gar nicht brauchen kann.
Also ich persönlich finde es ja noch schlimmer, wenn jetzt auch noch personalisiertes Spam kommt.
Also ich will überhaupt gar keine Werbung haben.
Nee, personalisiertes Spam, weiß ich nicht, ob man das so nennt. Also die müssten auf jeden Fall, wenn sie Werbung verschicken oder verschicken wollen, das Einverständnis des Users haben. Und dann eben über die Firmen gehen, sich quasi anmelden für diese Werbung. Und dann, wie gesagt, müsste es natürlich Geld kosten, weil es ist ein enormer Aufwand, der da produziert werden muss. Aber dann hören diese endlosen Spams auf, die von irgendwelchen Firmen kommen, wo man überhaupt nicht weiß, was ist es eigentlich, wenn man da draufklickt.
Das Problem ist, was du ansprichst, sind dann diese sogenannten Opt-in und Opt-out-Verfahren, wo man also entweder explizit einwilligen muss, dass man Werbe-E-Mails überhaupt empfangen möchte oder die andere Seite wäre dann eben, dass man explizit sich irgendwo austrägt. Das Problem damit ist, es müsste ja dann in so einem Schema müsste es ja irgendwie eine Autorität geben, die dann sozusagen diese Listen entforst, die also etwas dafür tut, dass diese Listen eingehalten werden. Wenn jeder einfach Spam versenden kann und es überhaupt kein Risiko damit eingeht, weil es irgendwie auch gar nicht strafrechtlich oder wie auch immer.
So wie es derzeit der Fall ist.
Richtig, weil es gar nicht belangt werden kann, dann kann ich mir alle möglichen Sachen einfallen lassen, aber es hat halt keinen Zahn, der das dann letztendlich durchsetzt.
Ja, das muss Richtlinien haben, das ist richtig. Und ich sag mal, ich kann auch diese Diskussion dieser Betreiber verstehen, die dann auch sagen, die möchten dann irgendwann auch Geld für diese E-Mails haben. Das war ja schon in einer Diskussion gewesen. Weil die eben doch merken, dass sich diese Sachen auch lohnen, weil das ist ja auch Post in dem Sinne, die da verschickt wird, es war bloß elektronisch, aber trotzdem immerhin eine ganze Menge an Mails, die da pro Tag überhaupt auf der ganzen Welt so verschickt werden. Und das ist ja teilweise wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr, als wenn man SMS vom Mobilfunktelefon verschickt, und die kosten ja auch Geld. Und dass sie da was machen wollen, der Hinsicht ist eigentlich verständlich.
Ja, verständlich, dass sie das so haben, aber ich kann ja auch gleich sagen, wohin das führen wird. Sie werden einfach keinen Erfolg damit haben, weil 30 Jahre Internetkultur umzudrehen, das kann man einfach mal komplett vergessen.
Nein, ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass Firmen so eine Art Premium-E-Mail-System aufbauen.
Als Dienstleistung ist das ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung, aber das einzelne Empfangen von Mails oder so.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass irgendwann nachher irgendwelche Leute, weil sie sich das leisten können, sagen, ich hab nur noch ein Premium-E-Mail-Account.
So, Premium-E-Mail-Account.
Wo dann nur noch bezahlte Mails ankommt. So, dann kannst du den Leuten halt keine Mails mehr schreiben.
Das hat aber doch mit dem Traditionellen-E-Mail-System das Interesse.
Nee, klar, das ist ja was komplett Neues. Aber die Leute werden halt irgendwie keinen Bock mehr auf diesen Spam haben. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es irgendwann einen Markt dafür gibt.
Ja, aber es gibt auch, wir werden ja noch draufkommen. Also ich sehe das eigentlich gar nicht so negativ. Es wird sich schon in den Griff kriegen lassen.
Und da es ja auch so viele Leute gibt, die nicht eine E-Mail-Adresse haben, sondern gar mehrere, was ich auch eigentlich nicht verstehe, weil eine, denke ich mal, für jeden reicht auch aus. ZB sind es Gewerbetreibende, die dann die zweite vielleicht für die Firma brauchen.
Und dann bist du noch bei irgendeinem Verein, da hast du dann noch eine und bist hier irgendwo Mitglied oder machst dort irgendwo mit, dann hast du da auch noch irgendwelche E-Mails und Verteile, auf denen du bist.
Aber die braucht man nicht wirklich.
Also sei froh, wenn du nur eine brauchst. Ist doch super. Die Jungs hier haben sowieso die Schacke weg. Die brauchen halt 80, verstehst du? Aber manche brauchen mehr, manche brauchen weniger. Ist ja okay, wenn du nur eine brauchst, muss ich auch nur um eine kümmern. Sei froh. Vielen Dank für den Anruf, Björn.
Aber es ist natürlich richtig, dass sich mit der Anzahl der E-Mail-Adressen, die man hat, der Account, natürlich auch die Zahl der Spam-Mails potenziert.
Aber wenn hier solche Vorschläge kommen, wie zum Beispiel von Björn, das sind ja solche Sachen, also mit dem bezahlten E-Mail, das sind ja alles Geschichten, wo dann diese Sicherheit, die geschaffen werden soll, auf den Schultern der Nutzer ausgetragen wird. Weil wenn es auf einmal Geld kostet, muss ich als Nutzer dafür bezahlen. Was ich will, ist ja eigentlich, ich möchte mit dieser Scheiße nichts zu tun haben, möchte einfach da sitzen, möchte mein Ding so weitermachen wie bisher. Und die Leute, die den Service für mich anmieten, die sorgen bitte dafür, dass dieser Scheiß nicht durchkommt. Ich möchte in meinen eigenen Türsteher. Also interessant finde ich zum Beispiel, da habe ich jetzt...
Also bezahlte E-Mails, ich glaube, das ist wirklich der totale Holzweg. Mich erinnert das so ein bisschen an Brasil, mit diesem schönen Zitat, so ja, das war doch bestimmt Jenkins, der ist schon immer der Meinung, dass die Leute für ihre Verhörer mehr bezahlen müssen. Also da kann man jetzt einfach nicht die Leute damit bestrafen, weil die Leute, die die Infrastruktur bereitstellen, nicht peilen, wie das richtig zu betreiben ist. Also es ist nicht so, dass es technisch grundsätzlich nicht ginge, sondern es ist einfach nur so, dass ich erstmal einen technischen Konsens finden muss, um dieses Problem anzugehen und das ist jetzt gerade im Werden.
Zwei Sachen von unserem Board, die ich mal vortragen möchte. Das eine kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen, deswegen bin ich mal interessiert daran, was ihr dazu sagt von Birger, hat von Heise.de ein Zitat gepostet. Die Vierzahl der Ideen zur Spam-Bekämpfung wird durch eine Open-Source-Alternative bereichert. Das Projekt CAM-RAM hat ein System entwickelt, bei dem Mails von unbekannten Absender nur dann durchgelassen werden, wenn der Computer des Versenders vorher eine kleine Rechenaufgabe gelöst hat.
Da gibt es mehrere Projekte, die diesen Ansatz verfolgen. Wir sind da mindestens zwei Freie bekannt und auch Microsoft favorisierte in letzter Zeit ein derartiges Modell. Halt ich persönlich für schwer durchsetzbar. Man muss dann zum Beispiel an Leute denken, die ganz legitim sehr viel E-Mails versenden. Man stellt sich vor, man betreibt eine Mailing-Riste.
Zum Beispiel den Chaosradio-Ticker.
Zum Beispiel, auf dem auch wirklich nur die Leute E-Mails bekommen, die sich da explizit darauf eingetragen haben. Und wie soll ich dann sowas noch verschicken? Oder man bedenkt ja an ganz große Firmen, die eine Bank oder irgendein Online-Anbieter, der an seine Kunden ein Newsletter rausschickt, das kann schnell mal eine halbe Million E-Mails sein. Und wenn er jetzt für jede dieser E-Mail Rechner irgendwie eine Sekunde lang, wenn es nur eine Sekunde ist rechnen lassen muss, dann ist der Newsletter nicht mehr new.
Das ist natürlich krass. Dann noch eine Frage von MKFF.
Max, ich kann diese Information mit dem Stream nicht in dieses Forum reinschreiben, weil dieses Forum möchte, dass ich mich registriere und dieser Registrierungsvorgang möchte, dass ich meine E-Mail empfange. Und der Internetzugang, den ich hier habe, erlaubt mir nicht den Empfang eines E-Mails. Deswegen musst du das selber da reinschreiben. Aber ich kann euch sagen, der MP3-Stream läuft wieder. Und zwar unter den unter chaosradio.ccc.de angekündigten URLs.
Also, machen wir es mal ganz altmodisch. Wir machen das im Studio jetzt mal vor. Ich reiche dir jetzt ein Blatt Papier über die Theke. Und du schreibst mir von Hand die Information einfach auf und gibst sie mir dann zurück.
Habt ihr nicht einen Laserdrucker hier, auf den ich das...
So, zweite Frage von MKFF. Gerüchteweise sollen 70 bis 80 Prozent des weltweiten Spam auf eine Absenderliste von circa 300 Adressen zurückzuführen sein. Ist da was dran?
Nee, ist nichts dran. Es ist durchaus so, dass es bestimmte E-Mail-Provider gibt, die bevorzugt verwendet werden von Firmen, die eben Spam versenden möchten. Da sitzen einige vor allem auch in Fernost, weil sie da auch juristisch gar nicht greifbar sind und auch anderweitig gar nicht greifbar sind. Aber man kann da also generell keine solche Aussage treffen. Das ist also nicht wahr.
Wenn ihr auf ähnliche Weise schnell eine Frage stellen möchtet, fritz.de auf die Boards und dann auf das Fritz-Board gehen. Da haben wir einen kleinen Thread eingerichtet zum Thema Spam.
Danke.
Oder auch an 90headchaosradio.ccc.de Jetzt machen wir ja so ein bisschen Konkurrenzkampf zwischen Boards und Mail.
Gut, am Telefon ist der Paul. 0331 77 97 110 könnte er auch übrigens anrufen. Das ist der Telefon, ganz klassisch.
Ähm, ich hatte ja neulich erst eine Spam-Mail. Und ähm, wir haben irgendwie, mein Vater hat da irgendwie so ein Programm draufgespielt, womit man halt, das läuft überall das Programm Anti-Virus, so ein Virenscanner. Und damit kann man jetzt auch E-Mails scannen, hat mein Vater irgendwie so eingerichtet. Und in dieser Spam-Mail waren Virus, ein Wurm.
Ja, das kommt sehr häufig vor. Also das sind eigentlich grundsätzlich getrennte Phänomene, diese Viren und Würmer auf der einen Seite und Spam auf der anderen. Aber da eben beides sich häufig über E-Mail fortbewegt, wird das natürlich auch miteinander kombiniert. Also an Spam-Mails irgendwelche Würmer dranhängen, die dann unter Umständen auch dafür sorgen, dass dieses Spam-Mail gleich wieder weiter verteilt wird auf einen Rechner, der dann damit sozusagen geknackt wurde. Das ist wahr, ja.
Ich hab die Mail dann halt ja gleich gelöscht und was ich noch sagen wollte...
Kein Problem.
War's das denn schon, Paul? Okay, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Und der Christian aus Frankfurt oder ist am Telefon.
Abend.
Dein Beitrag zum Thema.
Ja, ich muss ja auch sagen, dass mich diese Stammel total nerven, weil ich noch immer von irgendwelchen Newsletter-Mails krieg, wo ich mich nie angemeldet hab. Und das kotzt mich total an, aber ich hab halt meine Adresse bei Web.de und das ist eigentlich ganz cool, weil da kann man sich halt so eine Einstellung machen, wo man an sich drei Posteingänge hat, wo man bei meinem Posteingang nur die Mails kriegt, die man auch in seinem Adressbuch hat und bei den anderen dann halt die, die irgendwie total voll mit Spam sind, die werden dann da gleich darin geschmissen und die kann man dann auch da löschen. Also das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, aber das nervt mich halt total, dass man so irgendwelche Leute Mails kriegt, wo man sich überhaupt gar nicht angemeldet hat. Da möchte ich mal wissen, wie die irgendwie an Adressen kommen, weil ich hab jetzt nicht so eine gewöhnliche E-Mail-Adresse und...
Tja, die Webbranche würde jetzt sagen, die Prospekte hast du doch auch in deinen Briefkasten, hast du dich auch nie dafür angemeldet.
Würd ich meine Adressen, das sind ja, weiß ich nicht, das sind ja über vielleicht andere Kaufhäuser rauszukriegen oder so, aber...
Die können die auch einfach erraten. Also ich kenne ja jetzt deine E-Mail-Adresse nicht, aber ich vermute mal, da ist unter Umständen dein Name irgendwie drin, plus irgendwelche Zahlen und so, und da nimmt man einen Vornamen, Datenbank, und schmeißt die Zahlen dahinter und dann geht das halt einfach mal raus. Und mit irgendwie Tobias0815 kriegst du bestimmt auch eine ganze Menge Domains, auch entsprechende Ergebnisse.
B-U-R-I?
Du verschickst irgendwelche E-Mails an andere Leute. Diese anderen Leute tragen dich zum Beispiel in ihr Adressbuch ein, oder du wirst automatisch in deren Adressbuch eingetragen. Dann fangen die sich irgendeinen Virus oder Wurm ein, der E-Mails an alle Leute im Adressbuch verschickt, oder der zum Beispiel den Inhalt des Adressbuchs wieder an so einen Spam verzeichnet ist, oder jemanden, der eine Liste von E-Mail-Adressen zum Versand von E-Mails pflegt, und schon bist du damit drin. Das geht also ganz schnell und hast du selber eigentlich kaum einen Einfluss. In dem Moment, wo du eine E-Mail-Adresse verwendest, wird es früher oder später passieren. Das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Benutzt du Mailinglisten? Benutzt du das Usenet in irgendeiner Form?
Das mit den Filtern und das man in unterschiedliche Mailboxen sortiert, je nachdem, ob das jetzt im Adressbuch steht oder ob bestimmte Schlüsselwörter drin vorkommen usw. Das ist eine Technik, die seit langer Zeit beherrscht wird. Die gibt es von den unterschiedlichsten Anbietern und alle gängige Software, sämtliche Mail wieder unterstützt.
Und man soll sich auch keine Illusion machen. Ich will jetzt niemanden konkret verdächtigen, aber es ist einfach generell so. Jede Mail, die durchs Netz geht, geht weitgehend unverschlüsselt über dieses Netz. Das heißt, jeder einzelne Provider, bei dem diese Mail durchgeht, und das im Zweifelsfall bei jedem einzelnen Mailversand einfach mal viele sieht, diese Mail. Und wenn der da ein kleines Skript laufen hat, wenn das nur irgendein Mitarbeiter bei denen ist, weißt du, der lässt da einfach mal drei Tage lang einen Sniffer mitlaufen, guckt sich einfach jede E-Mail, die von links nach rechts geht, einfach an, schreibt die E-Mail-Adressen auf eine Datei rein, und dann hat er schon wieder was zum Verkaufen auf Ebay. Das ist so einfach. Also man braucht sich überhaupt keine Gedanken darüber machen. In dem Moment, wo man seine E-Mail-Adresse benutzt, ist sie einfach schon mal ein potenzielles Opfer. Da lohnt es sich gar nicht, darüber nachzudenken, wie die da jetzt herangekommen sind. Entweder sie haben es geraten, sie haben es mitgeschnitten, sie haben sich aus einer Mailing-Liste rausstranschiert, oder keine Ahnung.
Irgendwelche Foren, wo man sich registriert hat, da geht es dann auch schon wieder los.
Kurz was anderes. Tim, was hören wir eigentlich gerade? Hier ist nämlich eine Mail gekommen, dass jemand wissen will, was wäre...
Was hören wir denn eigentlich gerade? Wir hören glaube ich gerade das Kraftfutter-Mischwerk. Und das ist was ganz Tolles, aber ich glaube auch, was unveröffentlicht ist. Also wir haben das auch in unserem Camp-Video benutzt und ich glaube unter kraftfuttermischwerk.de wird da Informationen.
Christian, danke dir erstmal für den Anruf. Zwei Sachen aus dem Board. Eine Anmerkung von, sehr schöner Nickname, depressiverhypochonder, arme Sau. Er hätte einen Account bei mail.de und zwar mit Y geschrieben. Und er sagt, es ist ein spamfreies Mailkonto, weil das System von dem Teil sei, jeder, der ihm eine Mail schreibt, kriegt automatisch erstmal eine Mail zurück und muss einen Link zur Bestätigung anklicken. Und erst dann wird diese Mail zugesandt. Du möchtest einen Stift, ne? Und einen Zettel. Ja, kriegste auch.
Ich schreib dir jetzt alles auf.
So, ich hab hier gerade noch einen Zettel reingereicht gekommen. Da hat ein Bekannter mich angerufen und hat mir, der bei einem ISP arbeitet und der hat mal ein paar Statistiken über den gestrigen Tag laufen lassen. Die haben also gestern eben 80.210 E-Mails bekommen. Davon erkannte Spam-Mails aufgrund deren Spam-Filtersystem waren 23.500. Also die haben mit noch recht moderaten Filter-Einstellungen schon mal ungefähr ein Drittel ihrer empfangenen E-Mails als Spam aussortiert. Was ich noch als äußerst gering einstufe. Wenn ich da meine Statistiken, meine persönlichen angucke, dann sieht das Verhältnis auch eher so aus wie bei Tim, dass eigentlich 70 Prozent oder noch mehr für Spam und dergleichen draufgehen.
Der Jens hat uns geschrieben per Mail, dass er so einen eigenen Root-Server hat. Das ist also ein Server, den er selbst irgendwo hinstellt, den er betreibt bei einem Provider, der also sein Eigentum quasi ist. Und der will halt auch wissen, wie man so da irgendwas installieren kann, irgendwelche Spam-Filter und so was. Sagen wir dazu noch hier noch was? Ja, ne? Können wir schon noch ein paar Techniken...
Was sagt ihr zu diesem System hier mit der E-Mail und der Bestätigung? Das ist natürlich ein langerer Weg, wenn man immer erst mal klicken muss, dass man dann auch wirklich derjenige ist, der man ist. Aber wird das irgendwann nötig sein? Grundsätzlich?
Das ist übrigens diese Web.de-Geschichte, ne? Darauf spielst du an?
Das war jetzt hier dieses Mail mit Y, das ist jetzt ein anderer Provider. Vielleicht machen andere das auch, das weiß ich nicht.
Ne, weil wir haben das Problem, Web.de schickt dann offensichtlich automatisch so eine Nachfrage-Mail, so willst du in mein Adressbuch aufgenommen werden. So, und wenn wir jetzt so einen Chaos-Radio-Ticker raussenden, dann haben wir jedes Mal ungefähr 50 von diesen Mails oder so drinne. Bei uns, die dann da irgendwie ankommen, so irgendwie, möchtet ihr Chaos-Radio in mein Adressbuch aufgenommen werden?
Das heißt, das exklusive Freischalten, das ist eine der funktionierenden Techniken, wie man das verhindern kann, das Mail sozusagen unverlangt kommt, hat aber das Problem, dass jeder, der einem eben eine Mail senden muss, sich einmal freischalten muss.
Das hilft dir auch nicht, weil es bei mir auch zusehend immer mit gefälschten Absenderadressen verschickt wird. Dann hilft das auch nicht mehr. Dann hast du mir einmal eine E-Mail geschickt und ich hab dich bestätigt als timmetccc.de. Und morgen fängt jemand an, Spam-Mails mit deiner Absenderadresse zu verschicken und dann kommt er auch direkt. Das ist auch ein Mechanismus, der nicht hilft. Und wir werden auch nie einen Mechanismus finden, der vollständig greift. Aber zu den technischen Möglichkeiten kommen wir dann später.
Na ja, eigentlich hab ich mit Spam überhaupt kein Problem. Warum? Oder sagen wir so, nicht mehr. Eigentlich hab ich alles ausprobiert. Irgendwie mit Pein und anfangen rauszufiltern.
Inzwischen hab ich Thunderbird.
Das ist im Prinzip ja, für die es nicht wissen, Mozilla eben nur für E-Mails. Und das Ding funktioniert hervorragend. Das ganze Zeug, alles was in Spam reinkommt, ist relativ viel im Tag. Das Zeug fährt alles gleich in den Chunk-Ordner oder sofort in den Trash.
Aber du musst trotzdem dafür bezahlen. Aber du musst trotzdem dafür bezahlen.
Na ja gut, ich hab's halt IMAP.
Und IMAP ist ja nicht so das große Problem. Da bleibt das Zeug schön auf dem Server drauf. Und sozusagen, wenn ich länger online bin und für die Online-Zeit bezahlen müsste, fällt es in dem Fall nicht so sehr ins Gewicht.
Ja, aber der Mozilla muss das doch immer holen.
Nur bedingt. Also es stimmt zwar schon, dass bei IMAP in der Regel du nicht alles übertragen musst, aber wenn du einen Spam-Filter hast, der auf den Inhalte-E-Mail matcht, dann muss dieser Inhalt natürlich erst mal zu deinem Mozilla-Klein...
Der Header von der E-Mail...
Nein, nicht nur der Header, auch der Inhalt.
Du willst der im Inhalt noch Schlüsselwörter nehmen.
Du musst es auch komplett übertragen.
Das ist für den einzelnen Anwender nicht das große Problem. Das ist in der Masse das Problem. Guck dir mal bei so einem ISP an, wie viel Bandbreite drauf geht und wie viel Rechner der braucht. Dann kann er ein ganzes Rack voller Serverstellen, die nichts anderes machen, als VM-Scannen und Spam-Scannen und Filtern usw.
Ja gut, das ist in dem Fall das Problem vom E-Mail-Provider.
Das ist ein Problem des Netz allgemein. Wer bezahlt und dann ist endlich dafür.
Also so ein regionaler Provider hier in unserem Raum. Da läuft mal, das ist jetzt so eine sehr vage Zahl, aber nach meinen Erkenntnissen, pro Tag 1000 Euro Kosten für Spam auf. Das sind einfach schon mal 30.000 Euro im Monat, die wieder umgelegt werden müssen. Davon kann man 10 Leute beschäftigen oder eben auch nicht. Und das zahlst du natürlich alles mit. Und wenn du selber auch noch für die Traffickosten auf deinem Server bezahlst, auch wenn das dein eigener IMAP Server ist, dann kommt die Mail ja auch an und erzeugt Kosten. Trotzdem, also es ist natürlich schon so, dass diese E-Mail Clients wie z.B. Thunderbird oder auch Mail, auf dem Mac, Eudora, die haben jetzt alle solche Spamfilter mit eingebaut. Die funktionieren schon ganz gut, aber die muss man halt auch am laufenden Meter weiter trainieren. Und morgen gibt es halt schon wieder neue Spam-Techniken.
Das sind dann diese sogenannten Bayes-Filter, die so trainiert werden, die sozusagen auf gewisse Zusammenhänge, Text-Zusammenhänge innerhalb der Mail achten. Das heißt also, die gucken die Mail eher so abstrakt an, schauen welche Wörter, welche Buchstaben irgendwie im Zusammenhang stehen.
Wenn ein bestimmter Prozentsatz überschritten ist, dann greifen die erst.
Genau, das heißt also, du musst den vorher antrainieren. Du machst am besten zwei Folder, zwei Ordner in deinem Mail-Programm. Eines ist der Spam-Folder und eins der sogenannte Hem, heißt das ja irgendwie bei Spam-Assassin z.B. Das ist also sozusagen die gute Mail, die man haben will. Und dann sagst du ihm einmal so, das ist jetzt der Ordner mit den bösen Mails, mit den Spam-Mails, dann lernt er diese Text-Zusammenhänge ein. Und du sagst noch einmal, das sind die guten. Und dann kann er das irgendwie, je mehr du das machst, desto besser kann es dann eigentlich unterschieden werden.
Ja, man kann ihm auch sagen, alle die immer im Adressbuch drin sind, das ist erstmal kein Spam. Prinzipiell.
Ja, das hilft dir aber eben...
Das ist nicht verdächtig.
Ja, ist nicht verdächtig, aber es hilft dir auch nicht 100% eben in dem Beispiel, das ich gerade mithin genommen hatte.
Ja klar, das kann ich ja auch machen.
Und dann hast du nämlich das Problem, dass dir diesen Base-Filter ziemlich versauen.
Ja, wenn du die dann automatisch in deinen Hemmfolder einsortierst, dann konfigurierst du die...
Dann ärgert man sich danach.
Mittlerweile ist es auch so, dass die Spam-Versender Zitate aus Shakespeare-Büchern mit einfach in die Spams unten mit reinwerfen, die sozusagen total diffuse Wortgebilde enthalten, die dann die Base-Filter auch komplett aushebeln, solange bis du deinen Base-Filter so sehr gefiltert hast, dass er einfach auf jede normale Mail anschlägt, weil du ihn sozusagen mit so viel normalem Zeug gefüttert hast, dass einfach überhaupt keine Mail mehr durchkommt. Also das ist so eine Teillösung.
Bei mir funktioniert es inzwischen. Ich hatte noch Probleme, weil ich zugemüllt werde mit mindestens 20 Spams am Tag. Wenn ein extremer Tag ist noch mit wesentlich mehr.
Und bis ich da meine E-Mails rausgefischt hab, werde ich wahnsinnig.
Und seit ich jetzt einen Thunderbird hab, geht's relativ gut.
Na ja, lass uns mal in einem Monat darüber reden. Da passiert es schon wieder anders. Also ich hatte das auch vor kurzem, dass ich...
Ich benutze ihn jetzt schon seit über einem Monat.
Ja, das ist alles nur eine Frage der Zeit. Vor allem das große Problem ist, je mehr Spam da ist, umso mehr... Selbst wenn ein Filter greift, umso mehr landet in dem Spam-Folder. Und umso geringer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du dir wirklich noch mal die E-Mails anguckst, die in dem Spam-Folder drin sind. Und umso höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du False-Positives kriegst und dass doch mal echte E-Mails in diesem Spam-Folder landen. Kannst du jetzt sagen, na gut, interessiert mich nicht weiter, wenn da mal hin und wieder eine reinfällt. Aber wenn es jetzt gerade der neue Auftrag deines Geschäftspartners war.
Tom, dank dir für den Anruf.
Ich hab da eine Frage an die Hörer da draußen. Vielleicht gibt es ja auch jemand, der Spammer ist von euch da draußen. Also so zufällig. Wir fragen auch nicht nach dem Namen. Aber vielleicht könnt ihr uns mal erklären, es kommen ab und zu mal Mails, die einfach wirklich komplett sinnlos sind. Also da ist einfach nur Trash drinne. Es sieht halt aus, als wenn es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, koreanisch ist es aber irgendwie mit unseren Zeichensatz. Und wo überhaupt nicht klar ist, also da ist weder das Subject noch im Text irgendwas klar, so was die da von uns wollen.
Das ist Andy-Base.
Bist ja sicher.
Ich hab da so die Vermutung. Was ist das? Na, dass einfach Mails bewusst verschickt werden, ohne dass sie jetzt erstmal schlimm aussehen, die einfach nur diese Basefilter verseuchen sollen. Die also einfach nur dazu gedacht sind, dass dieses System der Bekämpfung mit ich, wir erkennen die schon irgendwie nach...
Glaubst du wirklich, dass es da sozusagen diese Verschwörung der Spammer da draußen gibt, die jetzt irgendwie gemeinsam darauf hinarbeiten, irgendwie diese ganzen Spamfilter unnütz zu machen? Also ich glaub, dass die Spammer da eher erstmal nur an sich selbst denken.
Die denken ja damit auch an sich.
Jungs, Jungs, Jungs, 23.03. Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir sind zu dritt hier im Bunde der Harald, der Tim, der Frank und meine Person, der Max. Thema heute Abend ist Spam, für den Fall, dass ihr gerade es eingeschaltet habt. Es geht um unerwünschte E-Mails, die kennt ihr sicherlich, die habt ihr alle. Wir reden über das Thema noch knapp zwei Stunden lang. Ihr könnt entweder anrufen unter 0331 77 97 1 1 0 und damit quatschen oder ihr könnt eine Mail schicken.
90.chaosradio.ccc.de 90.chaosradio.ccc.de Diese langweilige alte E-Mail Adresse.
Oder ihr geht auf unser niegelnagelneues, fetziges Board.
Wo man sich erst anmelden muss mit einer E-Mail Adresse. Sind die E-Mail Adressen eigentlich im Forum zu sehen? Nein, kann man entscheiden. Also vote dafür, wenn ihr noch ganz viel zu lernen haben wollt.
Also fritz.de da auf Boards klicken und euch da beteiligen. Wir haben ein Thread aufgemacht zum Thema Spam. So, wir haben jemanden am Telefon. Und zwar dein Kumpel. Ich hab den Namen jetzt schon wieder vergessen, Tim. Vom CCC Köln.
FD0 müsste das sein, oder?
Ja, wunderbar. Ich hab mir überlegt, irgendwann im Oktober letzten Jahres, ich möchte gerne wissen, wer eigentlich E-Mail Adressen von meinen Webseiten einsammelt. Und hab mir dann überlegt, dass man doch, wenn man eine Webseite aufruft, da dynamisch eine E-Mail Adresse generieren könnte, die für diesen Seitenaufruf eindeutig ist. Ja, und ich hab das Ganze dann mal gemacht. Und hab das aufgewetzt auf köln.ch. CCC.de slash snuki. Und am 2.10. habe ich das installiert. Und am 12.10. kamen schon die ersten Mails.
Also kannst du noch mal erklären, wie das funktioniert, was du dort genau gemacht hast?
Ja, wir können auch mal, wer jetzt da draußen das hört und ein Webbrowser hat, also köln.ccc.de und dann ein Schrägstrich und dann snuki.
Habt ihr denn auch Köln mit Ö registriert?
Wieso die, das müssen wir ja machen. Köln.ccc.de und ganz unten ist es auch verlinkt. Und wenn man dann auf die Seite kommt, bekommt man ganz viele E-Mail-Adressen präsentiert. Unter anderem sind da welche drin, die sind nicht verlinkt. Da sind welche drin, die haben anstatt des Ads eine Zeichenfolge A, T oder ein Ad nicht als Ad in dem HTML-Source, sondern als HTML-Entity ganz viele verkrüppelte E-Mail-Adressen auch dabei. Und damit wollte ich zeigen, also wollte ich versuchen, rauszufinden, ob Spammer das erkennen, also verkrüppelten E-Mail-Adressen. Und am 2.10. habe ich es installiert, am 12.10. kamen die ersten Mails.
Nach 10 Tagen sozusagen.
Das ist auch das, was wir ungefähr so mit den Chaosradio-Adressen machen. Also wir machen das ja auch, wir haben ja viele Sendungen, irgendwie neue Adresse, 90er und so. Und es ist auch so drei, vier Wochen ungefähr im Schnitt. So, denn aber auch richtig ordentlich.
Was jetzt an dieser Schnucki-Sache interessant ist, ich wollte ja wissen, wer diese E-Mail-Adressen einsammelt. Also habe ich mir überlegt, dass ich in diese eindeutige E-Mail-Adresse, die IP-Adresse, der Aufruf des aufrufenden Clients mit einstudiere. Also wenn jetzt jemand von T-Online diese Seite aufruft, dann wird die IP-Adresse in diese E-Mail-Adressen reinkodiert, die da auf der Seite sind. Das ist auch auf der Seite selber beschrieben, wie das funktioniert ganz genau. Und das heißt, wenn ich an eine dieser generierten E-Mail-Adressen eine E-Mail bekomme, kann ich genau sagen, wer diese Seite aufgerufen hat, auf der diese E-Mail-Adresse stand und zu welchem Zeitpunkt. Und da gab es eine ganz interessante Geschichte. Ich habe morgens meine Mail-Server-Logs beobachtet und da kam auf einmal eine Mail von einem deutschen Host, auch an eine der generierten Adressen, mit einer Anmeldung zum Euromail-Newsletter. Also so ein Erotik-Spam-Kram. Und da ich das ja live gesehen habe, habe ich mal gerade geguckt. Das war also eine T-Online-Adresse, von der die Seite aufgerufen wurde. Die ist irgendwie, also eine Traceroute hat mir gezeigt, dass sie vermutlich in Karlsruhe sitzt. Ja, habe mir die Alp-4-Adresse mal angeschaut, war ein Netblink-Router, ja, default-Passwortlist kennt man ja im Internet und 1-2-3-4 hat dann auch funktioniert. Und ich finde, diese Firma braucht keine Port-Weiterleitung des E-Donkey-Ports. Leider hat der Router dann disconnected, die ich da mit Spaß haben konnte, also, naja gut.
Hast du ihm wenigstens ein anderes Passwort gegeben?
Das muss ja nur auch sein. Also interessante Details dann noch. Also das ist 02web.de, das ist der Server, von dem das kam. Das ist eine Suße-Kiste, also ein Linux-Server. Und wenn man mal auf aeromail.de selber geht, dann gibt es zwei interessante Sachen. Und zweimal steht da mittlerweile seit Monaten ein Artikel drauf. Irgendwie, ja, Web-Hooligans haben unsere Datenbank kaputt gemacht. Es gibt keinen Anstand mehr im Netz. Es könnte jetzt sein, dass bezahlte Kunden unsere Nügel dann nicht kriegen und dass Leute, die ihn nicht bezahlt haben, ihn kriegen. Das ist so...
Nice try...
.wollen die sich entschuldigen, dass sie Spam verschicken. Und wenn man da nicht drauf achtet kann, also wenn man jetzt vom Computer nicht unbedingt den Plan hat, kann es ja sein, dass man da drauf reinfällt, dass man sagt, ja, die hatten einen Datenbankfehler, die haben das versehentlich verschickt.
Wie viel Zeit ist denn da vergangen zwischen dem, wo die Mail sozusagen gehavistet wurde, also von der Website geholt wurde?
14.10. ist das gewesen, letzten Jahres.
Und bis du dann die Mail auch bekommen hast. Du siehst auch in der Mail, wann die abgerufen wurden.
Der ist der gleiche Tag gewesen. Aufgerufen wurde die Seite am 14. Oktober um 7.52 Uhr und die Mail hab ich gekriegt um 9.56 Uhr.
Welcher User Agent war dann dabei, weißt du das auch noch?
Den User Agent hab ich leider nicht, weil wir auf CointiDee den Kram nicht bloggen. Die IP-Adresse hab ich auch nur.
Tim guckt sich grad ganz begeistert die Eros Mail.
Ja, vor ein paar Tagen ist es leider passiert, ein paar Web-Hooligans besuchten den vorherigen Server und zerstörten Bolt alles, was sie gefunden haben. Leider ging dabei auch der gesamte Datenbestand von EroMail drauf.
Die haben grad Schiss sozusagen. Haben wir eigentlich insgesamt diese haarwestigen Sachen schon mal ein bisschen erklärt, also wie die E-Mail-Adressen geerntet werden von Seiten? Oder hab ich das verschlafen?
Also wir haben es noch nicht erklärt, nicht wirklich, ne?
Also Tim, wenn du noch auf der Seite bist, dann klick vielleicht mal kurz auf Impressum.
Auf Impressum? Ist das das mit dem bunten Bild?
Genau, da bekommt man eine GIF-Datei, also ein Bild, das auf einem Schweizer Server liegt und auch auf eine Schweizer Firma zeigt.
Moment, Impressum, ach da, ja.
Irgendwo unten ganz klein.
Ja, war Skriplink.
Und da kommt dann ein Bild, das ist also kein Text, sondern wirklich ein Bild. Und das ist irgendeine Schweizer Firma, soweit ich in Erinnerung hab. Das passt irgendwie gar nicht ins Bild.
Also das sind jetzt schon sehr fortgeschrittene Methoden, wie man das in Bermas zurückverfolgen kann.
Hast du denn da mal Statistiken und magst du die vielleicht auch mal veröffentlichen? Weil ich glaube, das wäre mal ganz interessant.
Die Statistiken sind halb öffentlich, wenn man so möchte. Also die URL ist nirgendwo verlinkt, aber das ist auf schnucki.köln.cdc.de schrägstrich report. Alles klein, da ist dann das Ding. Also ich vermute mal ganz stark, dass sich das rumgesprochen hat, dass das ein Spam-Harvesting-Projekt ist. Denn das hat nach etwa kurz nach dem Kongress aufgehört, da Mails zu kommen. Also ich vermute mal, dass es sich da rumgesprochen hat. Ich hab auch im Kongress einen Vortrag über das, über Spam gehalten mit einem anderen Kölner zusammen. Und vermute ich einfach mal. Ja, ich hab mir so was gedacht. Ich hab parallel dazu ein zweites System aufgesetzt. Mit im Prinzip demgleichen. Also es wurde dann halt nur eine E-Mail-Adresse generiert, um es nicht gleich so öffentlich zu machen. Und das ist eine.net-Domain. Und da kommt wesentlich mehr. Also da hab ich gut jetzt 2000 Spam-Mails drin, jeweils an verschiedene Adressen. Da hab ich allerdings noch keine Statistik. Da muss man mal gucken.
Da fällt mir übrigens auch noch ein anderes interessantes Projekt ein, um den Spam an das Leben schwer zu machen. Da gibt es also auch eine Geschichte, die dann einfach die ganze Webseite voll wilden E-Mail-Adressen packen, die halt irgendwie komplett erdacht sind und irgendwie ins Leere gehen, nur um dann und auch, bekannt es halt auch über eine bestimmte Technik, die Verbindung lange offen halten. Das heißt also, um den Leuten wirklich irgendwie das abgerasene Webseite ein bisschen schwerer zu machen. Und ja, weiß nicht, wer da irgendwie Infos hat, postet das doch einfach mal ins Board, wer da Bock hat, irgendwie da die Leute ein bisschen zu ärgern. Auch. Mir fällt gerade der Name nicht ein. Hatte niemand parat?
Da fällt die Verbindung offen halten, das ist Tear Grouping.
Genau, richtig.
Also, kurz mal mal zu diesem Schnucki Zeugs. Ich bin nicht der Erste, dem sowas eingefallen ist. Und zum Beispiel ein Daniel Rehbein aus Dortmund hat das auch schon mal gemacht. Und hat viel Spaß mit der Firma Teleinfo gehabt. Denn die Firma Teleinfo hat im Juni, Juli 2003 ein Gewinnspiel gehabt und wollte ihr System da im Maps Scout bekannt machen. Das basierte darauf, dass man diese Werbemails an möglichst viele Freunde weiter schickt. Und dieser, ja, also es ist auf spamfang.rehbein.net und dieser Daniel hat halt auf vielen seiner Seiten auch diese generierten E-Mail-Adressen verteilt, die mit der IP-Adresse zusammenhängen. Und hat an diese generierten Sachen diese Spam-Mails bekommen. Und konnte dann ganz eindeutig, das war halt eine E-Mail-Adresse, die generiert wurde für eine IP-Adresse, die der Firma Tele-Info gehört. Und er hat da Tieres Stress mit Tele-Info gekriegt, weil die dann ihm ein Einschreiben geschickt haben. Offensichtlich werden bei ihnen sogenannte Daten am Fernmeldeverkehr gespeichert, verarbeitet und sogar an Dritte oder an die Öffentlichkeit übermittelt. Wir werfen uns nebelös eine Verwicklung in sogenannten Spam vor und so weiter, also sehr lustig nachzulesen. Auf spamfang.rebein.net. Also der hat da richtig Spaß gehabt.
Nochmal spamfang?
Spamfang, also die fangen. Punkt rebein.net, wie das Reh und das Bein. Da ist die ganze Sache erklärt, wie er es gemacht hat. Da ist unten irgendwo ein Link auch zu der Story mit Teleinfo.
Adressensammler identifizieren ein Beispiel.
Ja, genau.
Danke dir auf jeden Fall für den Anruf erst mal aus Köln. Wir müssen die Sache jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen runterköcheln. Weil ich sehe auf den virtuellen Stirn unserer Hörer gerade auch schon IP-Adressen. Worum geht es denn eigentlich? Aber vielen Dank für die Einsichten.
Du unterschätzt die Chaosradio, oder?
Ich unterschätze auf gar keinen Fall alle. Ich muss auch sagen, dass euer Blick für Details mir gefällt. Das ist immer so dieses Ding. Wenn du darauf gehst, dann siehst du ein Foto von einem Schweizer Banker, der einen Siegelring trägt. Auf diesem Siegelring ist ein Biber. Und der gleiche Biber ist 1982 in der Chaosradio-Lounge aufgetaucht mit einem Feuerwerkskörper. Dieser Feuerwerkskörper enthielt nur, und ich betone, nur gutes Gras. Verstehst du, so geht das halt bei euch nur. Das sind diese Verknüpfungsgeschichten.
Fantastisch. Beginnt es uns langsam vollständig zu durchschauen.
Übrigens, ich möchte das einfach mal vorlesen. Die hat Emre bei uns in Sport geschrieben unter fritz.de als Provokation. Irgendwo sind die User aber auch alle selber schuld dran, wenn durch ihre schlecht gewarteten und mit Viren infizierten PCs die Spammer ihre Nachrichten absetzen können. Mal im Ernst, die E-Mail-Programme und Betriebssystem Monokulturen fehlendes Sicherheitsbewusstsein tragen dazu bei, dass die Spammer Rechner finden, die sie ausnutzen können. Und solange die Werbung vorgaukelt, dass man nur zwei- bis dreimal rumklicken müsse, bis man auf seinem Parkettboden liegend Filme im Internet gucken kann, solange werden die Leute im Netz auch als offene Scheuntore unterwegs sein und zur Werbeflut beitragen.
Das ist nicht falsch.
Das ist so richtig. Ist was dran natürlich. Es ist ja schon so, dass man als diese Spamproblematik begonnen hat, angefangen hat, das E-Mail-System etwas zu verbessern an den Punkten, wo es da angegriffen wurde. Nur, das ist halt so ein Wettrüsten, was da im Laufe der Zeit entstanden ist. Früher war es eben so, dieses wissenschaftliche Internet, wo keine kommerziellen Interessen verfolgt wurden, da hat einfach jeder Server jede E-Mail von jedem angenommen und an jeden beliebigen Empfänger weitergereicht. Das sind sogenannte Relays. Alle Relays waren also, alle Rechner, die E-Mails verteilt haben, waren Relays, die waren offen, jeder konnte an jeden Server einfach E-Mails zustellen und die wurden dann weitergereicht. Das wurde natürlich maßlos missbraucht von den ersten, die da angefangen haben, Spam zu verschicken. Dann hat man diese Relays geschlossen, zunehmend. Heute gibt es zumindest offiziellerweise nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viele offene E-Mail Relays. Man hat also eben da Überprüfungen eingebaut und jeder nimmt nur noch E-Mails an, die tatsächlich für ihn selbst bestimmt sind und nicht mehr für andere Leute und hat eben das sukzessive immer weiter verbessert. Aber das ist eben ein Wettrüsten. Dann lassen sich die Spammer wieder einen neuen Mechanismus einfallen lassen. Das ist mit den Filtern genauso. Dann gibt es dann Spamfilter und es gibt wieder Spammer, die versuchen, absichtlich um diese Spamfilter so herumzukommen. Das ist wie ein kalter Krieg.
Ganz kurz noch eine Zwischenfrage, jetzt von dumm User gesehen. Ich kann mich da durchaus reinversetzen. Jetzt gibt es ja die Behauptung, z.B. von Microsoft, sehr, sehr großes Unternehmen und ohne das jetzt von vornherein verteufeln zu wollen, sagen die ja, wir kriegen in ein paar Jahren das Problem in den Griff.
In zehn Jahren gibt es keinen Spam mehr.
Wir werden irgendwelche Trusted Networks aufbauen oder was auch immer. Der Begriff Trust wird ja jetzt ganz, ganz groß geschieden.
Wenn es erst in zehn Jahren keinen Spam mehr gibt, dann brennt dieser Planet. Also ich glaube, das Fass ist bereits total voll zum Überkochen. Aber es gibt jetzt schon durchaus technische Lösungen, die vielversprechend sind.
Aber übrigens zu dieser Trusted-Geschichte, da hat uns der Azu eine Mail geschrieben. Wie wäre es denn, wenn man einfach nur noch Mails annimmt, die mit PGP oder GPG signiert sind? Das ist also abgeleitet von einem Verschlüsselungssystem eine Idee, dass man also Mails digital unterschreibt, um damit den Absender eindeutig feststellen zu können.
Das Ansicht bringt dir auch noch nichts. Das Ansicht bringt dich nicht weiter. Wem wird erlaubt, so eine E-Mail zu signieren? Wenn jeder selber seine E-Mail signieren kann, dann kann das Beimer auch seine E-Mail signieren und dann ist die E-Mail genauso signiert wie alle anderen und du wirst sie auch wieder annehmen.
Gut, man könnte ja sagen, das ist mit mindestens einer anderen...
Na ja, gut, dann denkst du dir 500 auf.
Also mit X5109, mit dem FK-Hierarchie könnte das schon gehen. Das könnte natürlich auch schon für die Mail-Relays an sich, also für die Mail-Server kennen, denn da weißt du auf jeden Fall die Kette, wo es herkommt.
Aber du weißt auch, wie viele nützliche E-Mail-Arten es gibt, wo eine Verschlüsselung einfach nicht in Frage kommt, weil sie automatisch generiert werden, wo du nicht problemlos diese Verschlüsselung mit integrieren kannst.
Gut, aber man könnte das Problem ja auf die Server weiter verlagern. Also, dass du nur von trusted Servern überhaupt Mail annimmst.
Ja, aber du weißt auch, wie viel Performance das kostet, das zu tun.
Das mit den trusted Servern hilft ja auch wieder nur bedingt weiter, weil dann gibt es eben wieder den Windows-Heim-PC, der durch die entsprechenden Sicherheitslöcher ausgenutzt wird und der dann als Spam-Relay missbraucht wird. Und der schickt dann die ganzen E-Mails an seinen Provider. Und der Provider schickt sie dann mit originalgültigem Zertifikat und über die verschlüsselte Verbindung weiter und verteilt den Spam.
Das ist richtig, das würde man auch gerne gemacht. Das ist jetzt gerade so die neueste Masche von den Spamern, dass sie jetzt anfangen, Würmer zu verschicken, die sich die Leute dann durch einfaches Anklicken auf den Mail auf ihren PC holen. Dann passiert eigentlich gar nichts weiter, überhaupt nichts. Also da gehen keine Fenster auf, da wird nicht der Computer runtergefahren. Da installiert sich nur ein kleiner Mail-Server, der dann wieder Mails weiter leitet, die also von Spamern dahingeschickt werden und von da aus wieder verteilt werden. Das heißt, die Spamern nutzen also dann den sozusagen gekaperten PC als Spam-Verteiler. Genau.
Der Matthias ist am Telefon. Hallo Matthias.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur mal erzählen, ich hab irgendwie schon lange Zeit mit E-Mails und Internet zu tun und hat mich irgendwie auch ziemlich angekotzt, dass ich irgendwie über Jahre hinweg immer mehr und mehr Spam gekriegt habe und hab alles Mögliche ausprobiert, diverse Filter, auch Thunderbird, der hier vorhin mal gefallen ist. Funktioniert alles ganz toll, bis die ganzen Mails, bis dann einige Mails einfach verloren gehen, die man doch kriegen wollte.
Ja, die Fals-Positives.
Genau. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, okay, probierst du es, nimmst du dir eine neue E-Mail-Adresse, hab auf, war alles bei GMX, hab auf meine alte E-Mail-Adresse so einen Autoresponder gesetzt, der dann automatisch den Leuten geschrieben hat, Achtung, ich hab eine neue Mail-Adresse. Hab dann allerdings zumindest, wollte mal ausprobieren, wie es funktioniert, die Mail-Adresse halt nicht im Klartexten geschrieben, sondern so dieses typische Ad, also nicht dieses Ad-Zeichen, sondern einen AT dazwischen gepackt. Und vorher war ich so bei einem Spam-Haufkommen von, ich denke mal so 100 Spams am Tag. Und ja, zwei Tage nachdem ich das geändert hatte, diese mehr Adresse, war ich wieder so bei 80m. Naja, da muss doch wirklich jemand von Hand auswerten.
Nein, der Knackpunkt dabei sind die Adressbücher. Du schickst dann mit diesem Autoresponder den Leuten, also deinen Freunden, die auch immer die Leute, die dir legitimerweise eine E-Mail schicken, die neue E-Mail-Adresse, die tragen das in ihr Adressbuch ein. Und dann wird einer davon von irgendeinem Wurm wieder ausgenutzt und sendet den Inhalt des Adressbuchs an so einen Spammer.
Aber innerhalb von zwei Tagen? Das würde ja bedeuten, dass die Leute, die mir E-Mails schicken, ich meine, so viele Leute waren es nicht, die davon Info gekommen haben.
Wir haben das vorhin schon mal erwähnt. Also wenn du in diesen zwei Tagen überhaupt deine E-Mail-Adresse benutzt hast, das heißt, wenn du auch nur eine einzige E-Mail verschickt hast, dann reicht das schon vollkommen aus, wenn du irgendwo, irgendwo ein einziges Mal eine E-Mail hinschickst. Weil diese E-Mail geht über Computer, sie geht unverschlüsselt, da braucht nur ein kleines Skript mit laufen, was sich der durchschnittliche Perl-Programmierer irgendwie in zehn Minuten zusammenhackt und schreibt einfach alle E-Mail-Adressen, wo Mail herkommt, einfach in eine Datei. Das ist so simpel und es wird unter Garantie getan. Und das ist die einfachste Methode.
Ja, also es gibt durchaus unterschiedliche Ansätze, wo man immer wieder versucht hat, so durch temporäre E-Mail-Adressen, also E-Mail-Adressen, die nur eine bestimmte Zeit lang gelten, dem Problem zu entkommen. Das funktioniert aber auch nicht. Das ist im Prinzip die Steigerung von dem, was du jetzt manuell mit einer E-Mail-Adresse gemacht hast. Es sind Leute, die dann z.B. sagen, jede Woche habe ich eine andere E-Mail-Adresse ganz automatisiert. Und so irgendwie nach einem Monat verfallen dann die Alten immer. Und dann taucht diese E-Mail-Adresse vielleicht irgendwo auf in einem Mailing-Listen-Archiv oder irgendwo in einem Adressbuch von einem Freund. Aber bis diese E-Mail dann bei einem Spammer angekommen ist, so ist die Theorie nach diesem Monat oder so, dann ist die E-Mail-Adresse schon wieder nicht mehr gültig. Aber das Einzige, was man damit tut, ist, dass man seine ganzen Freunde und Bekannte nervt, weil die sich ständig neue E-Mail-Adressen merken.
Ja, und nicht nur das, du machst ja auch, also gerade im Usenet, also wenn ich jetzt mal bei Google, bei den Groups irgendwie mal schaue, dann finde ich es ja auch irgendwie interessant, einfach auch Leuten zu antworten, die mal irgendwo vor einem Jahr was gepostet haben, mal irgendwie eine Frage gestellt haben und mal nachzufragen, so ey, was ist denn, hast du da eigentlich jetzt schon was, eine Lösung gefunden oder so, das schätze ich sehr.
Was ich ganz spannend fand, es stand bei uns im Board eine Geschichte, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das so gemeint war, aber es kam mir zumindest die Idee, da stand, dass er, dass jemand seinen Bekannten immer ein Keyword sagt, dass sie sozusagen als betreffend eingehen müssen, was im Grunde so ähnlich ist wie ständig die E-Mail-Adresse.
Das ist auch wieder so eine Opt-in-Geschichte oder so eine Positivliste.
Aber es ist eben ganz interessant, insofern, als wenn du zum Beispiel jemand bist, der im Newsnet unterwegs ist und dann einfach unten als Signatur schreibst, pass mal auf Leute, wenn ihr mir eine Mail schreibt an diese Adresse, dann bitte mit dem Betreff lalala, alles andere sehe ich mir nicht an, das wird sich der Spider nicht merken können, weil der guckt nur nach der E-Mail-Adresse und nicht nach dem zugeordneten Passwort in Anführungsstrichen.
So weit sind wir noch nicht zum Glück.
Ja, aber da macht ja keiner mit, wenn man das seinem Freundeskreis sagt, die haben es in zwei Tagen wieder vergessen.
Du kannst das natürlich machen, wenn du eine E-Mail-Adresse hast, die du wirklich nur für irgendwelche Postings nimmst, dann ist das ja eine Sache, wo man sagen kann, okay.
Ich meine, ich hab mir bis jetzt sonst auch mit so Weckwerfadressen weitergeholfen.
Ja, wie gesagt, das Problem ist eben, es kommt nur drauf an, es gibt Leute, denen passt das, denen gefällt das, die haben kein Problem damit, wenn ihre E-Mail-Adressen irgendwann wieder nicht mehr gültig sind. Aber bei mir persönlich würde das überhaupt nicht passen. Ich bedauere immer noch, dass ich, also nur noch die E-Mail-Adressen seit 1994 sind gültig bei mir. Da erreicht man mich noch, aber die vorher, da erreicht man mich nicht mehr, weil es die einfach nicht mehr gibt, die Doments. Also es kommt immer drauf an, was man macht. Aber wenn man sehr viel mit dem Netz zu tun hat und auch längerfristig erreichbar sein will, dann möchte man persistente Adressen haben, möchte nicht, dass sich die ständig ändern.
Danke dir für den Anruf, Matthias. Der Cylon schreibt hier bei uns im Board, das hatten wir heute auch schon mal gesprochen, bevor wir die Sendung angefangen haben zum Thema Spam, E-Mail-Adress einfach als Bild auf die eigene Homepage stellen, als Bild, damit kann so ein Spider das nicht crawl.
Das ist ein bisschen annoying für die Leute, die mir schreiben wollen, wir müssen die dann von Hand abtippen. Aber ist auf jeden Fall erstmal ein ziemlich zielsicherer Schutz gegen dieses Harvesting.
Cylon ist noch ein bisschen krasser unterwegs, als du insofern, als er gesagt hat, um OCR zu umgehen, könnte man auch eine Flash-Animation nehmen. Gibt es da wirklich welche, die mit OCR das Ding checken?
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Anbieter. Macht das Orkut nicht auch? Ne, die haben Klartext. Es gibt so ein paar Systeme, die dann so eine Human, also eine Menschterkennung sozusagen machen. Also dass halt wirklich ein Mensch da sitzt, indem sie die Zahlen zum Beispiel verzerren. Also wie so ein komischen Zerspiegel oder so.
Ja, wenn du dir einen AIM-Account machst zum Beispiel, bei Orkut ist es ähnlich, aber einfach um Robots zu verhindern. Genau, mit so einem VARBA-Filter da drüber in unterschiedlichen Farben und gerastet und so, sodass wir das halt wahrnehmen können. Aber damit kann man halt schon ganz gut zwischen Menschen und Maschinen unterschreiben.
Es ist halt wieder genau dieses Wettrüsten, was ich angesprochen habe, bedauerlicherweise.
Der Robert aus Solingen ist am Telefon. Hallo Robert.
Ja, schönen guten Abend.
Dein Beitrag zum Thema.
Ich habe verschiedene etwas grundzusammenhängende Geschichten, die ich kurz erzählen wollte. Das erste, ich habe meine Mail-Adresse hauptsächlich bei GMX. Ich habe es mittlerweile einfach so gemacht, dass ich sämtliche Absender automatisch auf die Blacklist gepackt habe. Das heißt, es landet eigentlich alles im Spam-Folder. Ich habe mir einfach die bekannten E-Mail-Adressen rausgesucht mit der Zeit. Das ist im Prinzip auch zwar nicht direkt ein lernender Filter, sondern von mir selbst dann eingerichtet. Mittlerweile ist es eigentlich so, dass ich die meisten Mails dann automatisch dadurch einigermaßen gefiltert bekomme. Wenn dann was mit einer gefalschten Absenderadresse reinkommt, dann muss ich darauf achten, dass ich es nicht aufmache. Was in meinem Fall allerdings auch egal wäre, weil ich kein Windows benutze. Das ist also eigentlich nicht so ein Problem. Man muss halt den Spam-Bericht dann schon mal im Auge behalten, denke ich. Damit kann man eigentlich einigermaßen klarkommen. Was benutzt du? Also eine etwas rabiate Möglichkeit, aber ich denke mal, bei meiner Firewall habe ich das ja genauso, dass ich alles zumache und halt gucke, was ich dann haben will.
Ja, das ist schon richtig. Aber der Unterschied ist halt irgendwo, dass du bei einer Firewall üblicherweise auch nicht unbedingt jetzt angenommen, wenn du hast einen Webserver laufen und hast eine Firewall, dann filterst du üblicherweise auch nicht auf Quelladresse raus, sondern du filterst auch Zieladresse. Und das ist bei E-Mail ja sowieso schon gegeben, weil du eh keine E-Mails bekommst, die nicht an dich gehen. Also da hinkt der Vergleich ein bisschen. Es geht vielleicht ja in vielen Fällen beim privaten Anwender, aber stell dir vor, du willst so ein Schema bei einer Firmen-E-Mail-Adresse machen, wo irgendwelche Leute, denen du auf der Messe mal eine Visitenkarte gegeben hast, oder die dir jetzt vielleicht ein Angebot von dir wollen, dich anmelden wollen, von denen hattest du nie vorher was, und da ist dann auch der Kreis nicht so abgesteckt, wie jetzt im privaten Freundeskreis.
Ja, das ist mit Sicherheit bei einem größeren Unternehmen ein ganz anderes Problem, aber im privaten, wo ich vielleicht regelmäßig Mail von maximal 20 Leuten kriege oder so, da geht das eigentlich einigermaßen. Zum Beispiel mal Usenet, hab ich vorhin gehört, dass die Leute in ihre Signatur was reinschreiben, das mach ich mittlerweile auch so, weil das bei mir wirklich explodiert ist mit dem Spam, nachdem ich ein paar Postings nur geschrieben hatte, war meine Mailbox dermaßen überfüllt, das ging überhaupt nicht mehr.
Aber du erzählst eigentlich auch zu spät, oder?
Das verändert einfach, sodass derjenige, der mir, wenn überhaupt mal per E-Mail eine Antwort schickt, dann das Stück halt rausschneidet. Und das geht dann eigentlich auch. Dann hab ich im Internet gerade eben gelesen, dass versucht wird, Software zu entwickeln, die halt eine Verifizierung ermöglicht. Ne, das ist ein neues System von der Firma hier aus Solingen. Die nennen das E-Mail Verification System, EVS. Haben da leider nur sehr spärliche Informationen dazu. Das ist ein bisschen schlecht, aber die versuchen wohl anhand irgendwelcher Informationen, die halt mitgeschickt werden, den Absender zu überprüfen, was natürlich voraussetzt, dass beide Seiten diese Software benutzen.
Sie haben 10.000 Patente darauf angemeldet.
Ich kenne die Firma persönlich nicht so gut. Ich habe das nur auf der Website. Haben sie das groß angekündigt. Ob das wirklich jemals funktioniert, weiß ich nicht. Aber es ist halt ein Ansatz, irgendwie was zu versuchen.
Es gibt durchaus eine ganze Reihe von Ansätzen. Das große Problem bei diesen Ansätzen ist, dass sie leider häufig von den falschen Leuten kommen. Nämlich immer von Unternehmen, die damit Geld verdienen wollen. Und zwar alle mit ihrer Lösung. Deswegen haben wir so viele und kein einheitlichen Standard. Es gibt VeriSign, die wollen eine neue Top-Level-Domain. Punkt Mail aufmachen, in denen sie Verifikations-Records speichern, weil damit können sie Geld verdienen. Sie sind ja eine Domain-Registry. Dann gibt es Firmen wie Microsoft, die eine ähnliche lizenzpflichtige Datenbank aufbauen wollen, damit können sie eben auch wieder Geld verdienen. Dann gibt es die Firma aus Solingen und es gibt hunderte bis tausende weitere, die das gleiche versuchen. Ich bezweifle, dass irgendjemand davon Erfolg haben wird. Im Internet funktionieren gemeinhin eigentlich immer nur offene Standards, die irgendwo spezifiziert werden in der AETF oder in anderen Standardisierungsgremien und die Hersteller unabhängig sind und irgendwie die Interoperativität gewährleisten. Ja, das ist richtig. Da gibt es mittlerweile eine ganze Reihe Ansätze. Es gibt eine sogenannte ASRG, eine Spam Research Group, die versucht, hier unterschiedliche Verfahren zu analysieren usw. Aber das steckt halt alles noch in der Entwicklung.
Ja, das wird sicher auch noch einige Zeit in Anspruch nehmen. Aber ich hoffe, dass sich da was tut. Auf jeden Fall bei größeren Unternehmen etc. Natürlich der Spam ist eine extreme Belastung. Die verlieren ja wirklich Kohle dadurch, dass sie sich um sowas kümmern müssen. Dann hab ich noch abschließend eine kleine Anekdote. Ich hab nämlich letztens irgendwo gelesen, da gab es wirklich eine Stellenanzeige im Internet, wo jemand gesucht wurde, der sich damit auskennt, wie die Proviser die eingehenden E-Mails filtern, um also höchstwahrscheinlich dann entsprechende Umgehungsmöglichkeiten zu finden.
Hast du da eine Quelle noch?
Kannst du mir das beschreiben? Da müsste ich noch mal nachgucken, das war irgendwo ein Newsgroup-Posting.
Oh, mach das doch, das wäre geil.
Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Wenn du jetzt nicht mehr telefonisch durchkommst, dann kannst du es auch posten unter fritz.de ins Foto.
Oder mail an 90 hat Chaos.
Ins Board oder?
Ja genau, fritz.de. Ja, an 90 hat Chaosradio.
Schick's doch per E-Mail, dann wissen wir deine E-Mail.
Alles klar, dann könnt ihr mich auch zuspamen.
Der Lothar hat übrigens ins Board geschrieben unter fritz.de. Jetzt reagiert Frank schon gar nicht mehr. Dass wir gleich mal ein bisschen mehr Musik spielen sollen, dass er das Thema total geil findet, aber er möchte was von der guten Musik hören, das machen wir gleich. Vorher werden wir uns allerdings mit den Nachrichten beschäftigen. Matthias hat sich gerade wieder rausbegeben und hat gedacht, er kommt jetzt nicht zum Zuge, aber es war ja ein schnelles Tschüss vom Robert. Insofern können wir jetzt eben ganz kurz die Nachrichten durchziehen und danach geht's sofort weiter mit der Sendung.
Wenn Fritz in Eberswalde, dann 100, 1.
23.31 Uhr.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter. Nachts ist es Stern und Laber. Die Fäden zwischen 5 und 1 Grad. Am Tag ist es dann meist heiter. Nur ab und zu schieben sich so ein paar Wolken vor die Sonne. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 16 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
UN-Generaltritt Herr Anan hat bei den Zyperngesprächen noch nicht aufgegeben. Er traf noch einmal den Ministerpräsidenten Griechenlands und der Türkei. Die Verhandlungen waren festgefahren, als sich der Führer der griechischen Zyprioten weigerte, ein Papier über ein Referendum zur Wiedervereinigung der Insel zu unterzeichnen. Im Mannesmann-Prozess können alle Angeklagten nach dem bisherigen Stand der Beweisaufnahme mit Freisprüchen rechnen, das sagte die Vorsitzende Richterin. Es gebe keine Anhaltspunkte für Untreue gegenüber der Mannesmann AG. Bei dem Prozess geht es um die umstrittenden Millionenzahlungen nach der Übernahme durch Vodafone. Als erstes Bundesland führt Bayern die 42-Stunden-Woche im öffentlichen Dienst ein. Für Beamte geht die längere Arbeitszeit vom 1. September an. Von Mai an werden Angestellte und Arbeiter nur noch dann eingestellt oder befördert, wenn sie 42 Stunden arbeiten. Zum Sport die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft der Männer hat in Köln gegen Belgien 3 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Frauen-Nationalmannschaft schlug Italien mit 1 zu 0. Unter Verkehr auf Ritz, wir haben keine Meldungen. Weiter eine gute Fahrt.
Mit den Ritz DJs T-Birds und René. Was haben Sie?
Ich mag Spam nicht!
Gibt doch nichts über Spam, oder?
Extra für Lothar. Die Quelle bitte nochmal für alle, die Monty Python nicht kennen.
Die Quelle, ja, das ist dieser großartige Spam-Sketch, der auch der Namensgeber der ganze Geschichte war. Also Spam ist ja eigentlich ein englisches Produkt. Spiced Porked and Meat heißt das. Und in diesem Sketch, wo sie halt versuchen, irgendetwas ohne Spam zu bekommen, die ganzen Computerszenen, die ganzen Hacker lieben natürlich Monty Pilsen. Und deswegen war das dann irgendwann der Name, weil diese unverlangte Mail, diese UCE, wie sie damals noch hieß, war einfach genauso wie das Spam in diesem Sketch. Und seitdem heißt es einfach Spam. Die Firma, die diesen Spam herstellt, also die Originaldose mit diesem gewürzten Fleisch, die hat natürlich da seine Probleme mit, hat aber auch schon die Säge gestrichen, meint auch schon, naja, wir wissen ja, dass das jetzt der Begriff ist, aber wir werden schon froh, wenn ihr sozusagen eine unterschiedliche Schreibweise macht und wenn es irgendwie groß geschrieben ist, dann ist es unser Produkt und wenn es kleingeschrieben ist, dann ist es der Begriff. Aussichtslos. Sehr sportlich auf jeden Fall.
Das ist doch mal nett. Ansonsten wird das Zeug aber doch immer noch gekauft, oder?
Bestimmt, also in Britannien auf jeden Fall.
0371 77 97 110 ist die Nummer, wenn ihr telefonisch teilnehmen wollt. Heute hier auf das Chaosradio. Wir beschäftigen uns mit dem Thema Spam. Das habt ihr vielleicht so ein bisschen rausgehört, gerade kam das im Gespräch ja schon mal vor. Wir sind gerade bei der Halbzeit vorbei, das heißt noch knapp 1, 5 Stunden Zeit zu talken heute Abend auf Fritz. Ihr könnt auch eine Mail schicken. An 90atchaosradio.ccc.de Sehr empfehlenswerte E-Mail-Adresse, immer gut, gerne.
Viel besser als das Forum.
Das natürlich nicht. Fritz.de, einfach hin posten, wenn ihr möchtet. Und zwar auf interaktiv gehen auf Boards und dann im Fritz-Board findet ihr so einen kleinen Thread zum Thema Spam, der auch wächst und gedeiht. Das sind sehr, sehr viele schöne Ideen. Ich weiß nicht genau. Ich kann sogar sagen, dass zwischendurch schon mal was gefallen ist. Aber es sind vor allen Dingen Links da auch verzeichnet, die heute im Laufe der Sendung gefallen sind. Also wenn ihr mal was wissen wollt, da haben wir bestimmte Projekte.
Spammer ist übrigens auch mittlerweile sehr kreative Methoden. Tim, du kennst es ja auch. Wer so einen Web-Blog hat, der benutzt vielleicht das System Movable Types und haben sich auch ein paar Spammer mittlerweile reingefunden und haben festgestellt, wie man automatisiert Kommentare posten kann. Und das machen die auch ganz fleißig.
Nicht nur Kommentare, wie ich mittlerweile rausgefunden habe. Aber ich hab neulich sogar schon Spam in meinen eigenen Web-Blog-Einträgen gefunden und ich rätsel noch, wie das denn jetzt passiert ist. Offensichtlich gibt es da irgendwie noch nicht nur eine nicht bekannte Sicherheitslücke. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall. Ich bin so durchgegangen und hab den Kommentar Spam aus dem Eintrag rausgenommen, hab mir den Eintrag angeschaut und da war da auch Penisverlängerung drin.
Ich hab das nicht durchgeschrieben, hast du ja. Kein Kommentar.
Allerdings bei Movable Type gab es auch diese Sicherheitslücke, dass man doch bitte die Rechte auf seinem Server für Mail-Versand, wenn bestimmte Sachen, also wenn du einen bestimmten Eintrag oder einen Kommentar bekommst, kann dein System ja dir selber eine Mail schreiben. Das konnte missbraucht werden, soweit ich weiß, zum Mail-Versand von Spam.
Ja, es ist Perlcode, also da geht alles.
Aber man kann es auch fixen, da man den Code ja hat. Das ist der Vorteil.
Ja, also auch gerade in der Webblogsphäre ist es ein richtiges Problem, weil natürlich da dieses Kommentieren und dieses lebendige Diskutieren in Foren ist ja beim Fritz-System genauso, hat einfach eben genau dieses Problem. Jeder kann so einen Eintrag generieren und dann tun sie da halt ihre Links drauf, um bei Google irgendwie wieder besser dazustehen. Oder dass die Leute, was weiß ich aus welchen Gründen, einfach auf diesen Kommentar draufklicken und gehen jetzt auch dieses Thema an. Also gerade diese Company, da SixApart, die das Moveable Type macht, die hat jetzt so ein Registrierungssystem Zentrales losgetreten und setzt da drauf. Da bin ich noch nicht ganz so sicher, ob das so eine gute Idee ist. Naja, aber wir wollen jetzt auch mal nicht nur so viel klagen, sondern wir wollen jetzt auch mal ein bisschen was darüber erzählen, was man denn wirklich tun kann und dass eigentlich, wie es aussieht, mindestens eine wirklich gute Lösung auch in Sicht ist, die das Problem unter Umständen wirklich beheben kann.
Vorher vielleicht noch ganz kurz der Ferhat hat uns den Vorschlag gemacht, den Spammern einfach ihren Kram zurückzuschicken. Spammails und nicht nur einfach, sondern irgendwie 10.000fach, weil man hat ja ihre Absenderadresse. Klarer Fall von funktioniert leider nicht, blöde Idee.
Ja, eben. Also ich würde mal sagen, dass unter 5% des Spams mit gültigen Absenderadressen verschickt wird.
Und noch schlimmer, die anderen existieren ja tatsächlich und die Leute sind ja unschuldig, die eigentlichen Absender. Das heißt, die werden dann irgendwie beleidigt, beschimpft und wissen nicht mal irgendwie, worum es geht.
Wobei das ja auch schon wieder eine Form des Spams ist, dass man Spammails bekommt, die einen eben beschuldigen, dass man Spammails verschickt hätte, was man wahrscheinlich nicht getan hat. Es sei denn, man hat das über ein Virus tatsächlich getan, wo man dann denkt, oh Gott, ich hab was Schlimmes gemacht. Oder irgendwie so was wie, sie schlafen mit meiner Frau, sie schweinen. Und dann denkt man sich, Mensch, hab ich gar nicht gemerkt, muss gestern gewesen sein. Und dann geht man da drauf und dann ist da irgendwie eine Exe, die man runterladen soll.
Ja, ja, so was. Es ist alles ganz dramatisch, was auch vor ein paar Wochen irgendwie angefangen hat oder vielleicht auch schon länger. Ich weiß es nicht, dass eben dadurch, dass jetzt die Mail nicht nur von einer ungültigen, sondern von einer falschen, aber gültigen Mail-Adresse kommt. Die geht dann die Spam aber an eine ungültige Mail-Adresse, also von einer gültigen gefälschten geht es an eine nicht existierende. Das Mail-System, das diese Mail empfängt, sagt, den User gibt es hier gar nicht. Und irgendwelche Leute, die davon nichts wissen, kriegen jetzt sozusagen die Spam oder den Virus als Fehlermeldung des anderen Mail-Servers zurück, was ja schon häufiger mal passiert und nehmen das dann deswegen wiederum besonders ernst. Und dann steht da drin, na ja, und der Grund steht in dieser Datei. Und klick mal drauf und dann ist es schon wieder zu spät.
Also derartige Fehlermeldungen, die auf Spam mit gefälschten Absendern kommen, die sind tatsächlich sehr häufig geworden. Also ich muss sagen, gerade in den letzten Wochen würde ich sagen, von dem Spam, der noch durch meine Filter durchkommt, ist das ein ganz erheblicher Teil, sozusagen so 30-40%. Es sind tatsächlich nur Fehlermeldungen von, die dir als Antwort generiert wurden auf Spam-Nachrichten, die mit meiner Absendadresse verschickt wurden.
Danke übrigens an Andreas für die Mail mit diesem Jobangebot, für den Spammer-Job.
Der Christian aus Berlin ist am Telefon. Hallo, Christian.
Guten Tag, ich habe mal eine ganz dumme Frage wahrscheinlich. Wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus mit Linux? Oder wie sieht es dann aus, wenn ich meine E-Mail online lese, also nicht direkt auf meinen Rechner lasse?
Sondern du meinst per Web-Mail, oder wie?
Das ändert am Spam eigentlich nichts.
Also andersrum, was hat denn jetzt Linux da in dem Zusammenhang?
Na ja, also wenn ich jetzt mit Linux arbeite, hat es Vorteile eher oder ja nicht.
Wenn du jetzt auf dem Klein sozusagen mit Linux arbeitest, oder auf dem Server mit Linux, auf dem Klein. Na ja, es hat auf jeden Fall den Vorteil, dass diese ganzen Windows-Viren und Trojaner erstmal nicht ausführbar sind, was schonmal ein echter Vorteil ist.
Oder beziehungsweise mit alten Windows-Programmen, Beispiel Windows 3.11 oder Windows 95, da ist ja auch nicht mehr so toll.
Viel Spaß.
Da gibt es viele Sicherheitslücken, die überhaupt nicht mehr gefixt werden, weil Microsoft keinen Support mehr dafür anbietet. Also das bringt dich glaube ich auch nicht weiter. Also in Bezug auf die Menge des Spams, den du empfängst, wird es eigentlich keinen Einfluss haben, was du für ein Betriebssystem verwendest. Du hast unter Linux genauso viel Spam mehr als bekommen. Der Vorteil ist eben tatsächlich nur, dass eventuell in dem Spam enthaltene Viren, Sorianer und dergleichen auf dich keinen Einfluss haben und auf deinen Rechner. Aber du wirst deswegen noch genauso viel Spam mehr als bekommen.
Aber es wird auch irgendwann Würmer und Viren für Linux geben, wenn da der Markt, also wenn der Marktanteil größer ist.
Ja, also das muss man ganz fair sein. Das ist keine Eigenschaft, die irgendwie bei Linux inherent besser wäre. Wenn irgendwo ein Programmierfehler in einer E-Mail gelegt ist, dann ist das eigentlich egal, in welchem Betriebssystem das passiert. Wenn der Fehler ausgenutzt wird, dann wird er eben ausgenutzt.
Und online, das ist doch nicht. Also wenn ich es mir online irgendwie bei irgendeinem Web runterlade, also nur angucke und ich weiter mal, bzw. ich sehe es und gleich wegschmeiße, dann habe ich dann schon den Spam mit drin, oder nicht?
Der Spam ist da auch dabei.
Also du meinst jetzt aber diese irgendwelche Würmer und Trojaner?
Ja genau, genau, genau, genau. Die da sich dahinter verstecken.
Naja auf jeden Fall, wenn sie erstmal nur auf dem Server liegen, musst du sie erstmal aktiv runterladen. Wobei, ja doch, klar, musst du natürlich dabei machen.
Also das denke ich nicht viel Unterschied, du musst bei beiden einfach draufklicken.
Also könnte ich gleich im Leimer schmeißen.
Das ist mit Sicherheit der beste Weg, ja. Aber egal bei welchem Betriebssystem oder mit welchem Browser oder mit welchem E-Mail-System du deine Mails liest.
Scheiße.
Vielleicht zum Abschluss noch eine Frage. Was würdest du denn machen, wenn du so einen Spammer vor dir hättest?
Meint der jetzt eine E-Mail?
Nein, der Typ stellt dir vor, du bist auf einer Party und da ist so ein Typ vor dir und der sagt, oh geil, ich hab irgendwie diesen Monat schon irgendwie 3 Millionen E-Mail-Adressen vollgespammt.
Ich würde dann ein paar Jungs anrufen, die dann halt hier. Sonst gibt es da so eine Leute im Basten, die dann mal so eine Sachen hochanlienen, aber ich weiß nicht, wie das hergehen würde.
Das ist klar, russische Inkasso macht auch andere Aufträge. Übrigens hier in Eintracht von Archer, der glaube ich, bzw. Robert, der auch bei uns schon angerufen hatte und uns erzählt hatte über dieses Newsnet-Posting mit dem Link zur Stellenanzeige Marketingpersonal mit Kenntnissen über Eingangsfilter der Provider gesucht. Er sucht noch, hat er geschrieben, aber zu dem Beispiel, was man macht, wenn man so jemanden mal trifft, respektive findet. Er hat geschrieben, es gab in den USA mal eine Aktion, ist ihm eingefallen, wo Leute die Postanschrift eines Spammers rausbekommen haben und da dann massenhaft Kataloge und Pakete hingeschickt haben.
Kann man ja mal machen, also so Einfachbestellungen, Fernseher, Handys, Telefone, was will ich nicht, kann man ja zubauen an den Typen.
Ja, ist aber natürlich schwierig, weil stell dir mal vor, der hat sich getäuscht irgendwie und das ist halt doch nicht derjenige, der es gemacht hat, dann wird es echt schwierig.
Also ich wüsst nicht, was ich machen würde mit so einem Typen. Das ist genauso, wenn einer dir seine Newton-Torche zerkratzt. Das ist ja auch die gleiche Frage, wahrscheinlich. Und du siehst den, wie er das noch macht, vielleicht.
Ja, ja, da wissen wir ja net, was passiert.
Genau, und ich glaube, das würde wahrscheinlich jeder machen.
Ja, und da fällt mir der Film The Big Lebowski ein zu dem Thema.
Da gibt es eine schöne Stelle.
Was würdest du denn machen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das Jungpreis ist.
Ihr könnt es ja sagen, wir sind ja jetzt nach 22 Uhr.
Also wenn du es wissen willst, schreib einfach eine Mail an timatpeitschenshop.de.
Wo hast du die denn jetzt wieder rausgefunden?
Sorry, ich hab einfach den Vornamen genommen und irgendwo hingesetzt.
Oder man muss sich wahrscheinlich eine E-Mail-Adresse so einrichten, die total selten ist und so Abkürzungen drin sind.
Bringt ja nichts.
Bringt alles gar nichts. Das Traurige ist, eigentlich bringt alles überhaupt nichts. Wir werden jetzt gleich mal ein paar Methoden beschreiben, die ein bisschen helfen und dann die, von der wir gerade glauben, dass sie ziemlich viel helfen wird, wenn sie denn dann mal umgesetzt wird. Aber ansonsten ist alles ganz schön schlimm.
Also bei mir ist das noch nicht so schlimm, weil meine E-Mail-Adresse ist wirklich eine sehr lange und nicht so eine bekannte, sagen wir mal so.
Ich grüße die glücklichen Menschen da draußen, aber ich filter glaube ich schon serverseitig an die 200 Spam pro Tag raus und es kommt nochmal 150 durch, pro Tag.
Ja glaube ich, also da bin ich echt froh. Also ich sehe auch schon ab und zu ein paar Sachen, wo ich einfach, kenn ich gar nicht, wie kommt denn das hier rein? Hä, hab ich gar noch gar nicht gehört, dort hier Absender, wo kenn ich den?
Übrigens Cylon schreibt unter fritz.de bei uns im Board, wenn mir ein Spammer über den Weg läuft und hole ich keine Leute, dann hauche ich dem direkt selber auf die Fresse.
Ja, brüder, dann macht man sich ja die Hände dreckig.
Ja, außerdem weiß man ja nie, was das für ein Typ ist. Vielleicht war der früher irgendwie mal Karate-Lehrer und ist frustriert und macht was anderes. Vielen Dank für den Anruf. So, der Martin aus Hamburg ist auf dem Telefon. Hallo, Martin.
Ich hab mal etwas namens Nerv mich nett aus dem Internet verwendet, um Mails zu versenden, wobei meine Mail-Adresse etwa nach 42 Stunden nicht mehr existiert.
Ja, das ist so eine Weckwerf-Mail-Adresse.
Genau, so was in der Art.
Das hatten wir ja schon mal gesagt, das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen blöd, also das ist halt wirklich, naja, die ist dann halt auch weg.
Ja, dann kann ich gleich auch wieder mich genauso wie ein...
Dann kann ich auch ohne Absender was verschicken.
Genau, dann kann ich gleich eine Absender-Adresse fälschen, am besten, so wie die Spammer auch, dann bin ich halt nicht erreichbar. Das ist aber nicht das Hindersache von E-Mails.
Na gut, aber reicht eben für beispielsweise irgendwelche Anmeldungen in irgendwelchen Foren.
Gut, ja, aber wenn dann in dem Forum irgendwas passiert, was dich vielleicht interessiert hätte, wo du eine Benachrichtigungs-E-Mail bekommen würdest, dann kriegst du das halt auch nicht.
Ja, das ist wiederum auch wahr.
Es ist halt so, wie jeden Tag seine Telefonnummer zu wechseln.
Ja gut, aber für diese Dinge, wo es wirklich nur nervt, dass man eine E-Mail-Adresse angeben muss und wirklich keine weitere Verwendung dafür hat.
Nicht für ein Fritz-Forum.
Na ja, dann leg ich mir dafür genau eine E-Mail-Adresse an. Ich hab eben gesagt, das ist einfach Müll. Müll-Ad, meinem Namen, was auch immer. Und dann, ja.
Und dann kommt er in den Müll.
Das lese ich dann nie, genau. Das landet gleich irgendwie in Def Null.
Martin, war's das?
Ich wollte noch was zum Thema sagen. Was würde ich mit einem Spanner machen?
Ja, gerne.
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich eher auf die Psycho Tour versuchen. Ihn einfach mal ansprechen, was bringt ihm das?
Die verdienen damit Geld, sonst würden sie das auch nicht tun. Das ist eine ganz einfache Motivation, die ist auch sehr nachvollziehbar.
Obwohl, wir hatten jetzt gerade so einen Kandidaten, der hat irgendwie für irgendeine Partei Werbung gemacht. Wer war es noch gleich? FDP, Republikaner oder so was?
Ja, in einem Abfallstrecken, das ist falsch.
Er hat Werbung gemacht für irgendeine Partei, ich weiß nicht welche. Er war aber so clever und hat in dem Quellcode seinen Usernamen, seines Mail-Programms sozusagen, also sein Nickname oder sowas drin gelassen. Und das Schöne war, mit diesem Nickname war er auch bei eBay registriert. Und siehe da, er hatte auch genau einen Artikel erworben bei eBay, nämlich eine CD mit zwei Millionen Bolten Mail-Adresses. Opt in natürlich.
So, der Timo aus Bautzen.
Ich mach mir ein bisschen Gedanken um die Intelligenzquotienten der Spammer. Denn wenn gleich immer wieder ganz kreative Sachen dabei sind, man hat tausend Mails gesehen und es ist plötzlich wieder was ganz Neues dabei, es ist auch wahnsinnig viel Dummheit dabei. Zum Beispiel, warum wird spanischer Spam an eine Adresse versendet, die ja ganz offensichtlich mit DE endet?
Weil es nichts kostet. Und du könntest ja Spanisch verstehen.
Ist aber doch extrem unwahrscheinlich.
Na, es kostet dir viel mehr Arbeit, das rauszusuchen, als einfach zu verschicken. E-Mails sind halt kostenlos. Deswegen schickst du halt einfach raus. Bevor die irgendwie ein Tool gestartet haben, was vielleicht unter Umständen irgendwelche Annahmen darüber macht, ob diese Mail jetzt passt oder nicht, schicken sie halt einfach raus. Das ist einfach das Massenprinzip.
Okay, zu der Frage passt auch, wie kommen die Spam-Adressen?
Also die haben die Harvester, die scannen die Webseiten ab.
Und wenn dort meine E-Mail-Adresse in Klartext da steht, wird die abgegriffen und ich krieg was. Da gibt es jetzt jede Menge Methoden, das zu verschlüsseln.
Wir hatten das mit dem Bild schon genannt.
Formulare, wo die Adresse gar nicht mehr auftaucht. Dann hat sich durchgesetzt diese Schreibweise mit AT und mit HTML-Entitäten, mit und, Raute 60.
Kann man alles machen, aber es kann echt noch mal die gleiche Antwort geben. Im Prinzip ist dagegen kein Kraut gewachsen. Wenn du deine E-Mail-Adresse benutzt, dann schickst du sie jedes Mal unverschlüsselt durchs Netz und da ist auch nichts dagegen zu machen.
Aber ich denke schon, dass die Großzahl der E-Mail-Adressen geharrwestet sind. Das heißt, die sind tatsächlich wirklich von Web-Adressen oder von Webseiten oder von News-Postings abgegrast.
Worauf ich hinaus will, ist, wie inwiefern sind Spammer heutzutage überhaupt in der Lage, diese leicht verschlüsselten Sachen trotzdem zu scannen, weil technisch wäre es ja möglich.
Ja, aber es macht keinen Sinn, weil es gibt noch so viele andere, die nicht verschlüsselt, die einfach so da liegen.
Naja, ich glaube, den Trick kennen die schon.
Ja, der ist zu alt. Das ist ja das, was ich wieder meine mit Wettrüsten. Dann fangen die Leute mit AT an, dann irgendwann machen die Spammer das mit dem AT. Dann fängst du an, das in ein Bild reinzupacken, und in einem oder in zwei Jahren machen die OCR. Also das ist einfach wirklich nur ein... Jeder macht es dem anderen ein bisschen schwieriger, der andere versucht dann wieder die Leute auszudricksen und so geht das hin und her.
Naja, beim Movable Type tun sie das AT als Unicode-Zeichen rein, dass es nicht erkannt wird, solange bis das auch jemand wieder rauskommt. Diese Leute, das muss man auch so sehen, Spammer verdienen eine ganze Menge Geld, da ist richtig viel Kohle in diesem ganzen Apparat drin, mit diesem Massenversand von Viagra und so weiter. Man darf nicht glauben, dass das nur irgendwelche Handel sind, die nichts Besseres zu tun haben in ihrer Freizeit, so was zu tun, sondern da ist Geld drin. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass diese Leute auch wirklich extrem begabte, ich will jetzt mal nicht Hacker sagen, aber netzsavvy Leute, die einfach wissen, was sie tun und die genauso das Netz beobachten, wie wir das auch tun, bloß eben mit einer anderen Intention, nämlich wie komme ich drum herum, was die anderen bauen. Und das, was alle einsetzen, sind vor allem die Open Source-Lösungen und die kommerziellen Lösungen. Und da ist ja auch klar dokumentiert, was die tun. Und genau da kann man dann wieder drum herum. Man braucht also ein System, was wirklich wasserdicht ist.
Kurze Frage mal, weil Pat hat hier bei uns schon mehrfach das gepostet, jetzt das zweite Mal. Deswegen lese ich es jetzt auch mal vor, damit er das nicht ein drittes Mal postet. Ihr habt vorhin das Thema Signieren abgetan. Euer Argument war, dass man einen Trust Center haben müsste, welches die Signaturen vergeb. Da ist nicht reicht, dass der Sender die Mail signiert. Was wäre, wenn man selbst als Empfängersignaturen verteilt? Man könnte also damit Mail erlauben und dass jeder einen Schlüssel bekommt. Was natürlich nur geht, wenn man irgendwie seine drei Kumpels hat. Wenn du irgendwie öffentliche Mails empfangen willst, geht das nicht. Aber die Frage ist zum Beispiel, passt natürlich nicht ganz rein heute Abend, aber was ist mit Instant Messaging? Das ist genau deswegen mehr im Kommen, weil man da ein Netzwerk hat, was relativ überschaubar ist, was für seine Freunde reicht. Wird hier auch immer mehr gemacht oder wird das auch schon mittlerweile von Spam beherrscht?
Also bei ICQ war das wohl mal lange ein Problem. Ich persönlich, ich benutze AEM viel, da habe ich das noch nie gehabt. Man kann da halt recht effizient blocken. Also in dem Moment, wo halt von irgendeiner, von irgendeinem Account was kommt, kann man den halt einfach blocken.
Ja, das kannst du bei E-Mails auch, dann nimmst du halt einen nächsten Account.
Das ist schon richtig. Also es ist schon vorstellbar, dass es demnächst genauso unter Attacke gerät. Aber dadurch, dass da eben viel über zentralisierte Server läuft, oder eigentlich alles über zentralisierte Server läuft, kann man da recht effizient gegen vorgehen. Also schnell berichten und so weiter. Aber das ist natürlich auch Missbrauchsgefahr.
Also ich muss sagen, jetzt im Internet Relay Chat, im IRC, nimmt es auch, je nachdem, in was für Netzen man ist, nimmt es auch deutlich zu mit dem Spam. Mag man ganz deutlich.
Timo, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. So, der Arne ist dran. Hallo Arne.
Ich hab vor, ja, vor einer Weile jedenfalls ein kleines Label gegründet. Und hab natürlich, wie sich das gehört, auch eine kleine Webseite zu dem Label gebaut. Natürlich, dumm wie man ist, wenn man gerade in so einem euphorischen Rausch ist, hab ich einfach die Labeladresse draufgetan. Und naja, ich krieg halt jetzt tonnweise Spam, aber das ist, naja, damit hab ich ja gerechnet. Ein großes Problem ist, dass diese E-Mail-Adresse wirklich sehr gerne zum Spam benutzt wird und auch zum Viren versenden und so weiter. Und das ist wirklich peinlich.
Ja, das ist richtig. Vor allem weil einfach das Wissen über das Internet und wie das funktioniert viel zu wenig verbreitet ist und du dann den Leuten erstmal klarmachen musst, nein, diese E-Mail hab ich nicht geschickt. Ja, da hat jemand den Absender gefälscht. Und das Beispiel, das da immer am besten hilft, ist einfach irgendwie auf den Postbrief zu verweisen. Man guckt auf den Umschlag und da kannst du auch was auch immer draufschreiben. Und das wird genauso funktionieren mit dem Postbrief. Das bei E-Mails ist auch nicht anders.
Ich habe auch inzwischen, ich beantworte die Mails nicht mehr. Also es ist schon echt ätzend. Jetzt vor einem Monat oder so war noch mal eine richtig krasse Welle. Da habe ich irgendwie mehrere tausend Antworten von irgendwelchen Mailservern bekommen. Hier, Adresse ist nicht. Und dann natürlich hinten dran die Mail, die ich angeblich geschrieben habe, das war schon ganz schön peinlich. Also es war auch so ein Penisverlängerungszeug und so weiter.
Ja, aber genau gegen dieses Fälschen von Absenderadressen, da gibt es mittlerweile eine ganze Reihe von technischen Ansätzen, die da helfen sollen. Ich hatte das vorhin mal ganz kurz angesprochen, es gibt da eine Standardisierungsorganisation im Internet. Das ist die sogenannte IETF, die Internet Engineering Taskforce. Und da gibt es wieder so eine Unterabteilung davon, die Internet Research Taskforce. Und die hat eine Arbeitsgruppe, die nennt sich ASLG, und in der werden solche Mechanismen evaluiert. Wie man also dieses Fälschen von Absenderadressen verhindern kann. Und da gibt es mittlerweile technisch sehr vielversprechende Ansätze, die auch leicht umzusetzen sind. Das Problem ist nur, da müssen viele mitmachen, dass es funktioniert. Wenn jetzt zehn Leute anfangen, so einen Mechanismus aufzusetzen, dass sie nicht mehr fälschen können, dann wird das die restlichen 99,999% des Internetes interessieren. Also es ist eben wichtig, dass man möglichst viele Leute unter einen Hut bekommt, die dann alle den gleichen Mechanismus verwenden, damit das Ganze funktioniert.
Also würde sowas dann auf der Klein-Seite gelöst werden?
Nein, das wird auf der Server-Seite gelöst.
Ach so, ich hab mir das gerade schon schwierig vorgestellt, ehrlich gesagt.
Nein, nein, das passiert nicht auf dem Klein. Grundsätzlich ist das ja so, wenn du eine E-Mail verschickst, dann geht das von deinem E-Mail Programm zu dem Server deines Providers. Und der verschickt diese E-Mail dann weiter an den E-Mail Server von dem Empfänger. Also den E-Mail Server des Providers des Empfängers, um es genauer auszudrücken. Und was man jetzt, also was man sowieso jetzt die ganze Zeit schon macht, ist, dass du schickst die E-Mail zu dem E-Mail Server deines Providers und dieser E-Mail Server muss dann herausfinden, welche IP-Adresse, welche Netzwerkadresse zuständig ist für den E-Mail Empfang. Der Ziel E-Mail Adresse. Ja, also du schickst jetzt an chaosradio.ccc.de schickst du eine E-Mail und dann muss der E-Mail Server deines Providers herausfinden, wer ist denn zuständig für den E-Mail Empfang von ccc.de. Und dann wird diese, da bekommt man dann eine Adresse zurück und dann wird diese E-Mail dorthin zugestellt. Und das aktuelle technische Verfahren, das eingesetzt wird, das macht dann hier Schluss. Das war es dann. Dann wird die E-Mail zugestellt und dann ist es zu Ende. Und diese Änderung, die man versucht einzubringen, die arbeitet immer auf dem Prinzip, dass dann der Empfang der Server, also der E-Mail Server vom CCC, der fragt dann auch erst mal ab, wer ist denn überhaupt autorisiert, eine E-Mail mit deinem Absender abzusenden? Und dann wird eben auch wieder in dieses Domain Name System hinein eine Abfrage generiert, wo man dann eben abfragt, welche Server im Netz dürfen überhaupt E-Mails versenden mit einer Absender-Andresse von dir? Und diesen Eintrag, den hat eben dein Provider dann in dieses DNS-System schon eingebracht und dann gibt es eben diese Überprüfung auf beiden Seiten und dann kann man eben gewährleisten, dass keine Adressen mehr gefälscht werden. Und da gibt es unterschiedliche Implementationen von dieser Idee, aber die grundsätzliche Idee bleibt immer gleich, dass man irgendwo im Domain Name System diese Information hinterlegt, welcher Server darf überhaupt E-Mails von einer bestimmten Domain absenden.
Mein erster Gedanke dazu ist, ich sniff mir einfach eine Mail ab, die halt signiert ist mehr oder weniger von dem Mailserver, wenn ich das jetzt gerade alles richtig verstanden hab jedenfalls. Und basteln mir, mein eigenen Mailserver ist ja nicht so wirklich schwer, und manipuliere so ein bisschen rum, dass ich jetzt Spam versende mit der Signatur eines Mailservers, der passenden Adresse dazu und so weiter.
Nein, das ist eben nicht die Signatur, sondern das steht in der DNS-Zone drin. Also dieses Domain Name System arbeitet ja so, dass es für jeden Namen wie ccc.de zum Beispiel eine sogenannte DNS-Zone gibt, in der stehen diese ganzen Adresseinträge drin. Und diese DNS-Zone, die kann nur von demjenigen verändert werden, der diese Domain registriert hat, in dem Fall eben der Chaos Computer Club. Und da kann dann der Administrator des Chaos Computer Clubs eintragen, es gibt einen Server, der heißt mail.ccc.de und der darf E-Mails versenden für die Domain ccc.de und sonst niemand. Und wenn jetzt die Leute, die E-Mails empfangen, wenn die dieses DNS-System befragen nach diesem Eintrag, dann funktioniert das eben.
Gut, vielen Dank für den Anruf, Arne.
So, Sekunde mal, wir mussten uns hier gerade so ein bisschen organisieren, weil offensichtlich, wir wissen nicht genau, was es ist, uns hat jemand darauf hingewiesen, dass es auf dem Web-Server der FP offensichtlich gewisse diskordische Schwankungen bei ihrem Dateninhalt...
Lass uns jetzt hier nicht gerade vom Fokus abkommen. Wir gehen da nachher noch mal drauf ein.
Können wir zum Ende machen, das können wir kurz vor eins noch feiern.
Ich hab hier eigentlich so eine Liste von so Wegen aus dem Spam und wollte eigentlich ganz gern mal so nacheinander kurz abhaken.
Ja, mach mal.
Haben wir denn diese SPF-Geschichte jetzt schon umfassend erläutert? Das war eben...
Sekunde, Jungs, Jungs! Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf.
Fritz, der Tim, der Frank, der Harald und der Max hier im Studio. Heute Abend zum Thema Spam. Unerwünschte E-Mails. So, jetzt können wir wieder die Schultern so ein bisschen nach hinten ziehen. Und jetzt können wir weitermachen im Thema. 0331 77 97 110. Übrigens die Telefonnummer, unter die ihr anrufen könnt. Oder ihr schickt eine Mail an 90 at chaosradio.ccc.de Oder geht auf unser Fritz-Bord, wo ihr auch eine ganze Menge nachlesen könnt über heute Abend. Fritz.de und da auf die Bords. Da gibt es einen Thread im Fritz-Bord drin. Könnt ihr relativ leicht finden.
Wollen wir nicht erst noch mal ein bisschen Musik hören?
Gut, wir hören erst ein bisschen Musik, vielleicht geht es weiter.
Schubidou, das kann man gar nicht richtig genug finden, finde ich.
Schubidou, du weißt, das Chaos Radio auf Fritz keine Stunde mehr, aber eine Stunde, da kann viel passieren. Heute Abend geht es hier auf Fritz im Talk um das Thema Spam und unerwünschte E-Mails und wir haben uns versprochen, wir gehen jetzt mal so eine kleine Liste durch an Gegenmaßnahmen.
Hab ich das vorhin richtig verstanden?
Ja, genau. Also das ist so, welche Wege es denn aus dem Spam gibt und wie erfolgversprechend die sind.
Der Frank hier im Studio, der Harald, der Tim und der Max, nur dass ihr ungefähr wisst, wie viele Stimmen ihr unterscheiden können müsst.
Genau. Also das erste, was wir auch schon am Anfang gleich genannt haben, ist so eine Geschichte wie die E-Mail Briefmarke. Also die Idee dabei ist, das Problem bei Spamern ist, dass ihr einfach kostenlos Millionen von Werbe-E-Mails raushauen könnt, ohne dass es ja auch nur einen Cent kostet. Also vielleicht von so einer CD mit den E-Mail-Adressen abgesehen. Die Idee dabei ist, irgendwie einen kleinen Mikro-Betrag, wie groß auch immer, für jede E-Mail zu nehmen. Vielleicht einen Cent oder vielleicht auch nur ein Zehntel oder nur ein Hundertstel Cent, um das einzuschränken, um einfach irgendwie diese Beliebigkeit der E-Mail ein bisschen einzuschränken, um das irgendwie abzurechnen.
Aber das kann doch nur eine totale Todgeburt sein. Also ich meine, wer soll wann, wem, auf Basis welcher Accountingdaten, über welches Abrechnungssystem, wie viel, auf welcher rechtlichen Grundlage, überprüft wodurch, also es kann einfach nichts werden.
Richtig, ja. Und dann muss man ja auch wieder in Betracht ziehen, dass der ganze Lebenshaltungsstandard und alles unterschiedlich ist, und dann werden eben die ganzen Spam-Mails nur noch aus der dritten Welt verschickt, weil dort die E-Mail-Bürge mal gebilliger ist als in Deutschland.
Das wird nie und immer was werden. Ich meine, jede Webcam schickt heute irgendwie E-Mails raus, und das wird einfach nie jemand in den Griff kriegen. Geschweige denn, das wird dann wahrscheinlich auch so ein unsicheres Framework werden, wenn das denn überhaupt jemals aufgesetzt wird, woran ich schon tief zweifel. Und sollte es das dann geben, dann wird es dermaßen viel Unfug hervorrufen.
Selbst wenn es dann mit irgendwelchen Tokens funktioniert oder sowas, dann kommen halt die Spanner und einfach Token, und dann sind halt deine Token weg und jemand spammt auf deine Rechnung.
Ich glaube, die Leute, die vorher Spam verschicken, verdienen dann Geld wiederum durch das Erzeugen falscher E-Mails auf Kosten anderer, was sie dann einsacken. Und das wird alles ganz furchtbar und grausam.
Was kulturell ist, zwischendurch hören, fragt man uns im Forum, ob das Musik von Telvin Singh sei.
Kenn ich doch.
Naja, das ist jetzt Matta, es kann sogar sein, dass das jetzt... Das ist von David Pike. Aber das Ganze ist jetzt von Badmarsh und Shree. Dancing Drums heißt das Album, ist eher so ein Bangra West Crossover Album, sehr schön. So, okay, was ist der nächste Ansatz, der nicht funktioniert?
Filtern von Spam, das heißt, sowohl das kleinseitige Filtern, also in meinem Mail-Programm, als auch das serverseitige.
Das ist die Fliegenklatsche, die Fliegen sind schon im Raum und jetzt haut man zumindest so lange drauf rum, dass das Problem im Hals nichts entgegenkommt.
Also ich muss ja sagen, also ich benutze bei mir Spam Assassin als Filter auf meinem Mail-Server. Ich bin in der glücklichen Situation, dass ich einen eigenen Computer bei einem Provider zu stehen habe, den ich selber administriere, der meiner ist, wo ich einfach tun lassen kann, was ich will. Und da hab ich einen Spam Assassin und bin da eigentlich soweit erst mal ganz zufrieden. Spam Assassin ist ein Software-Paket, was anhand von verschiedenen Kriterien Mails zunächst mal bewertet oder sogar auch schon ablehnt, bevor sie überhaupt angenommen werden. Das ist eigentlich eine Funktion, die ich am meisten schätze. Die funktioniert also zusammen auch nur mit dem Mail-Server-Programm. Das ist in dem Fall Exim. Der schaut die Mail an, wenn sie reinkommt und in dem Moment, wo sicher festgestellt werden kann, das ist Spam. Auch wenn die Mail noch nicht da ist, manchmal schon allein nur am Header, also an den Meta-Informationen sozusagen zu der Mail oder auch nach den ersten Zeilen der Mail wird irgendwann gesagt, also jetzt stopp, jetzt reicht, jetzt sind irgendwie alle Alarmglocken sind jetzt an, weg damit, geh weg. Das spart eine ganze Menge Traffic zum einen, auch den ich auch bezahle.
Und übrigens auch Geld, weil Spam Assassin ist freie Software.
Genau, da muss man nichts für bezahlen, das ist irgendwie sehr gut. Wird auch ganz gut gewartet und ist natürlich auch wieder diese Wettrüstengeschichte mit den Spamern. Das heißt also die Spammer können sich natürlich auch runterladen aus dem Netz, sie können sie installieren und werden ihre Mails solange trainieren, solange feintunen, bis sie dann irgendwann durchrutschen bei den Standard-Einstellungen.
Aber mal ganz ernsthaft, hat es einen Spammer wirklich, das kostet ja auch tierische Zeit, du musst dich ja schon damit beschäftigen, ist ja nicht was, was du von heute auf morgen hinkriegst, weil die Programme sind ja sehr gut und da schließt sich eine Frage von Oddo aus dem Board an. Machen die Spammer im Verhältnis zu den Kosten, die durch den Traffic bei ihnen entstehen, wirklich Gewinn?
Bei den Spammern entstehen ja keine Kosten.
Du schickst sie nicht?
Ich kann auch mit meinem DSL-Flatrate-Ding irgendwie Mails raushauen zum Beispiel. Oder ich nehme halt von irgendjemanden diese Viren- oder Trojaner-Geschichte. Das heißt, ich bringe dazu erstmal so einen Trojaner und das Volk, wo dann bei 10.000 Leuten da draußen ein kleine Mailserver aufgebildet wird, das PC und dann geht's von da aus weiter. Genau. Diese kleinen Filtergeschichten hatten wir auch. Ist natürlich das Problem, dass sie eigentlich nicht so viel bringen, weil ihr ladet ja die Mails dann auch erstmal runter. Das heißt, ihr habt dafür erstmal schon mal bezahlt in gewisser Form, sei es irgendwie Nutzung der Bandbreite beim Provider, die zwar so erstmal an sich flat ist, aber letztendlich ist das ja das Gesamtvolumen, was zählt und wonach dann auch der Preis für so eine Flatrate kalkuliert werden muss. Und die andere Variante natürlich, wenn ihr das über eine minutenbasierte Internet-Dial-Ableitung macht, so dann zahlt ihr letztendlich auch direkt über die Telefonrechnung dafür. Ist also auch nicht so das Wahre. Ist zwar ganz gut, weil es nimmt zumindest mal eine Aufmerksamkeit nicht in Anspruch, was man ja auch Geld spart, wenn ich die mal in Zeit umrechne, also meine Zeit in Geld umrechne, dann ist mir damit schon mal geholfen.
Aber diese Dial-up-Geschichte, das hatten wir doch auch schon mal besprochen, dass Dial-up von vielen da gewählt wird, weil man eben das nicht so schnell zurückverfolgen kann, woher das Ding jetzt kommt.
Ich meine jetzt für mich als User, also als Spam-Geschädigter, als Spam-Empfänger. Genau.
Als Spam-Konsument.
Als Spam-Konsument, genau. Einen interessanten Ansatz hat glaube ich Yahoo gemacht. Die haben angefangen, die Angebote, also die Webseiten, die in den Spam-Mails angeboten werden zu sperren oder eine Seite vorzuschalten. Lieber Kunde, sie klicken jetzt hier auf eine Spam-Seite. Werden sich darüber klar, was das bedeutet. Sie unterstützen Spam. Sie unterstützen irgendwie da so eine dubiose Geschäftemacher da draußen. Meistens sind das eh irgendwelche komischen Produkte, die da angeboten werden. Also überlegen sie sich nochmal, wollen sie da wirklich hingehen.
Und auch nicht sehr viel Erfolg haben, meiner Meinung nach, weil die Leute, die es wirklich anklicken, die wollen es auch sehen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich meine, diese ganzen vier Leute wissen nicht genau, was sie damit unterstützen, indem sie das anklicken. Ja, insofern ist so dieser sehr anzieherische Ansatz ja vielleicht nicht so schlecht.
Ja, aber die wollen Viagra haben, da kannst du nicht viel erzielen. Die wollen irgendwie das benutzen, einnehmen und dann die entsprechenden Vorteile, die dieses Produkt bietet, dann auch ausnutzen. Und du weißt, jede moderne Technologie funktioniert erst mal über Sex. So, das war beim VHS-Recorder, das war bei der CD, so.
Erinnerst du dich jetzt oder weißt du das nur?
Ich hab bei dir im Weblog nachgeschaut. Ich krieg ja übrigens auch gerade eine unverlangte SMS rein, wo über tatsächlich Spam-Probleme auch bei ICQ aktueller Art berichtet werden, dass Bots Accounts generieren und Hallo sagen als polnische Frau getarnt und sich dann einen auf Porno-Seiten locken. Wobei ich mich dann frage, wie eigentlich das Anmeldesystem bei ICQ funktioniert. Das hab ich noch gar nicht geschaut. Bei AIM haben sie halt auch diese Waba-Bilder, wo du dann halt den Text rauslesen musst. ICQ gehört ja auch AOL. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, warum das da so groß anders ist.
Und was man natürlich auch noch einfällt zu dieser Sperrung der Angebotsseiten, wo es dann hingeht nach der Spam, nachdem ich sie gekriegt hab. Wenn ich jemand ärgern will, dann nehm ich einfach seine Webseite, ich nehm einfach www.fritz.de und sag, da gibt's irgendwie Viagra und irgendwie Enlarge your Penis und spam damit alle Leute voll und die sagen, zu Ende gibt's nicht mehr. Und dann plötzlich stehen die Kunden da und der Provider hat die Seite gesperrt, weil sie irgendwie als Spam-Seite da aufgeführt ist.
Spärrung von Webseiten, das kann man ja schon seit Jahren spelen. Seit es Internet gibt, gibt es diese Idee und es ist immer noch der gleiche Heuchelweg.
Es gibt eine schöne Geschichte von einem, kann man jetzt mal sehen, ist er später nicht, vom Kollegen von mir.
Hört uns eigentlich jemand zu?
Keine Sau mehr, ist klar. Nee, vom Kollegen von mir, der einen kleinen Streit angefangen hat in einem Forum, wo es um ein bestimmtes Spiel ging. Ich sage jetzt mal nicht seinen Vornamen. Er arbeitet auch nicht bei Fritz, sondern er ist ein Bekannter von uns und arbeitet grundsätzlich beim RBB. Was dann so weit ging, dass irgendwann der gesamte RBB von seinen Computern keinerlei Zugriff mehr auf das Forum nehmen konnte. Auch sehr interessant. Soweit kann es gehen, auch wenn man von einer seriösen Adresse aus operiert.
Es gibt auch noch ein Spam-Problem, das wir noch gar nicht angesprochen haben. Das fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, weil mich das auch schon in den letzten Monaten sehr genervt hat. Das ist nämlich Spam über SMS. Und das ist so richtig bekloppt. Erstens, weil über SMS, wie wir alle wissen, durch das Antworten auf SMS, das kann ja dadurch auch hervorgerufen werden, mit irgendwie Hallo, hier ist Mausi und warum rufst du mich denn nicht mehr an und antworte mir doch mal. Und dann kostet jede SMS keine Ahnung, zwei Euro. Da gibt es dann so Kinder, die mal so locker über die Nacht mit solchen SMS-Chats extrem viel Geld verbraten. So, keine Ahnung, 250 Euro die Nacht. Das kann ja schon mal passieren. Das wird halt teilweise auch durch unverlangte SMS ausgelöst. Also einerseits gibt es natürlich diese Werbung mit schickt mir SMS und dann chatten wir die ganze Nacht. Das wird teuer, aber ich habe auch schon häufiger SMS auf meinem Telefon gehabt. Ich habe dann immer sofort die Service-Nummer von meinem Plastik-Provider angerufen und die erstmal angeschrien, also diese Leute da angeschrien, die ja eigentlich nichts dafür können, aber außer mir und dachte ich mir auch, wenn ich jetzt da irgendwie freundlich anfrage, ob man das nicht vielleicht mal ändern könnte, dann dringt das nie in die zwei zu der dritte Ebene davor, sondern ich habe den von vornherein klar gemacht, dass ich so richtig fuchsteufelswild bin und überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf habe und sofort den Provider wechseln werde, wenn das nicht aufhört. Allerdings war die Antwort immer die gleiche, die Nummern sperren und so. Wissen wir jetzt gar nicht und den können wir auch nicht rauskriegen. Wir wissen auch nicht, wer das ist, weil es sind diese fünfstelligen Absendenummern, zu denen man antwortet und dass die mir noch nicht mal sagen können, wer das schickt und vor allem, dass sie mir nicht den Dienst erlauben, sowas grundsätzlich zu verhindern, weil mich das grundsätzlich nicht interessiert, das ist natürlich sehr unseriös. Weil ist ja klar, daran verdienen die eine ganze Menge Geld mit und an der Stelle ist es auf jeden Fall noch nötig, zur Not auch über Gesetzgebung noch mal was zu erreichen.
Ja, genau, juristische Verfolgung, gutes Stichwort. Es gab jetzt glaube ich letzte Woche oder sowas mal wieder einen Ansatz da, so eine Gesetzesinitiative zu starten, es wird auch EU-weit diskutiert. Es ist ja auch in der EU immer noch so ein bisschen umstritten, es jetzt wenn es darum geht, ob die Leute Werbemails empfangen wollen, ob dann nach dem Opt-in oder nach dem Opt-out Prinzip gegangen werden soll. Das heißt also Opt-out heißt, wo die Leute aktiv sagen müssen so nein, ich will nicht, dann kann man sich noch irgendwelche Sperrdaten machen, so wie es früher gab die Robinson-Liste eintragen, so als wo man sagte so nein, ich will keine Werbung haben. Oder es gibt irgendwie die Fraktion, die sagt so nein, wir brauchen Opt-in. Das heißt wir gehen erstmal davon aus, dass grundsätzlich niemand Spam haben will, sondern nur die Leute, die sich aktiv irgendwo eintragen oder irgendwo das Befürworten, dass sie Spam kriegen oder Werbemails kriegen, die bekommen die dann auch. Und selbst diese Diskussion ist, soweit ich es verfolgt habe, immer noch nicht ganz endlich durch EU-weit.
Ehrlich gesagt, das würde auch eine Diskussion auslösen. Werbung generell an der Hauswand, die ist ja auch in Neuigen, wenn die da hängt, dann seh ich die und dann geht die mir auch auf den Sack und ich kann ja auch nicht entscheiden, ob ich sie seh oder...
Oder in den Bahnen, zum Beispiel, auf dem Fernseher oben.
Also das würde ja dann eine Diskussion hervorrufen, ob Werbung generell legitim ist oder nicht.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Nicht unbedingt, weil du eigentlich... Also das ist so ein bisschen der klitzekleine Unterschied noch, dass du...
Das wird ja wirklich in eine Privatphäre eingegriffen.
Das ist ähnlich wie bei Faxen, ja? Du musst erstmal... Bei Faxen hast du einen Papieraufwand, der dir entsteht. Bei E-Mails ist es irgendwo... Naja, es ist Traffic, der dir entsteht. Es ist Aufwand, der dir irgendwo entsteht und so weiter. Ja, hingegen jetzt bei Prospekten oder so, die sind halt einfach im Briefkasten. Und der Müll kostet dich auch nichts. Also, ich meine, der ist Altpapier, das Altpapier kostet dich nichts.
Wobei es da ja auch schon wenigstens die Möglichkeit gibt, die ja auch überwiegend respektiert wird. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ich mache einen Aufkleber ran, keine Werbung, dann klappt das ja auch gut.
Der auch rechtlich abgesichert ist. Ja. Aber da hast du auch wieder den Unterschied, dass eben nur ein Mensch innerhalb der deutschen...
Das ist ja auch wieder opt-out im Prinzip.
Das ist opt-out, aber es funktioniert deswegen, weil es erstens eine rechtliche Garantie gibt, dass dieser Aufkleber, dass du den Zweifelsfall auch einklagen kannst, dass du gegen die vorgehen kannst. Und zum anderen eben, weil derjenige, der das einwirft, das in Deutschland macht. Und dann tatsächlich auch einfach nur ein deutsches Gesetz gilt. Aber wenn ein US-amerikanischer Spammer über einen koreanischen Server dir eine Spam-E-Mail schickt, dann bräuchtest du ein eindeutiges internationales Recht, das du dann auch tatsächlich auch noch irgendwie durchsetzen kannst.
Ich denke, das ist wohl das Hauptproblem bei Spam. Und dazu kommt noch, dass viele Angebote, die sowieso schon mal illegal sind oder zumindest stark sittenwidrig sind, und damit sowieso irgendwie die Spammer schon von sich aus versuchen, irgendeiner greifbaren Gesetzgebung oder sowas aus dem Weg zu gehen, oder irgendeiner Strafverfolgung oder irgendwelchen Verfolgungen aus dem Weg zu gehen, und bilden da teilweise sehr abstruse Netzwerke über Firmen, Unterfirmen und Aufträge und so Geschichten, die dann wirklich in einem weltumspannenden Netz sind. Und bis die Justiz so weit ist, dass sie das weltweit verfolgen kann, da dürften noch etliche Jahre ins Land gehen.
Hören wir jetzt noch 40 Minuten Musik und war's das oder? Das hört sich so an wie so ein Schlusswort und so ein Ausatmer.
Ach nee, es gibt ja durchaus jetzt auch Ansätze, was man machen kann.
Man könnte natürlich den Martin noch mal ins Telefon nehmen. Was solltet ihr denn davon? Guter Plan. Ja, Martin!
Dann mal los.
Sorry für die lange Wartezeit.
Ja, ich werd mir den besten Headset zulegen, weil irgendwie das Telefon so lange halten macht keinen Spaß.
Das ist fast Pflicht für Chaosradiosendungen, dass man Headset hat mittlerweile.
Genau, der Preis, den man zahlen muss. Nein, ich wollte nur mal kurz erzählen. Ich habe mal einen Spammer kennengelernt. Oder ich kenne ihn und der war mal kurzzeitig Spammer sozusagen. Und das ist ganz interessant, die Gründe, die er hatte. Er hat es nämlich damit begründet, er hat irgendwo ein Angebot gesehen und hat eine Software gestellt bekommen. Und sollte eben so und so viele, weiß ich nicht, hunderte oder tausende von Mails bekommen. Und wenn er eben das gemacht hat, dann bekommt er danach eine Bezahlung. Also dafür bekommt er quasi Geld.
Für das Lesen von Werbung meinst du? Für das Lesen von Werbung?
Nee, für das Verschicken. Und dann eben er hatte das in dem Moment gemacht, weil es ja hieß ja, okay, danach gibt es Geld. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo er die ganzen E-Mail-Adressen her hatte. Aber eben dadurch können sich dann die betroffenen Leute, also für die geworben wird, die können sich dann da auch sehr schön, ja, außer Verantwortung ziehen, so aus dem Motto. Ja, ich war das ja gar nicht, so nach dem Motto.
Hat er denn Geld bekommen dann auch?
Nee, also ich weiß nicht. Aber eben, wenn natürlich da was ist, ja hier, du hast einen relativ minimalen Aufwand und du bekommst dafür Geld. Und mehr oder weniger du danach entweder du bekommst das Geld oder nicht und hast danach keine Probleme. Wenn du es nicht bekommst, dann ist es ja gar nicht so. Also vom logischen her...
Ja, will das nicht jeder? Irgendwas, wo man ganz wenig Geld, ganz wenig Aufwand hat und Geld damit verdient?
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist ein Spammer, der auf Scam hereingefallen ist sozusagen.
Ja, so ungefähr. Aber eben, ich wollte noch mal auf diese Diskussion zurück, von wegen was würde man machen, wenn man einen Spammer sehen würde? Dann sollte man nämlich eventuell noch mal nachfragen, warum er das gemacht hat. Und bei manchen Leuten, ja weiß ich nicht, das fängt mit den ganzen Viren und Würmern an, mit den ganzen Trojanen, dass sie darüber auch alles selber verschicken. Und dann wissen das die Leute teilweise gar nicht. Beziehungsweise er ist sich der Folgen quasi nicht bewusst. Aber das sind sie sich alle nicht. Manche sind sich, die meisten sind sich der Folgen nicht bewusst. Wahrscheinlich was sie damit anrichten bei anderen. Richtig, den ganzen Admins, die dann da tausende oder was ich will, mir jetzt einen Tag kriegen.
Der Marc hat uns übrigens den Hinweis gegeben, wo man dann SMS-Spam raushauen kann. Ich sag jetzt mal bitte nicht bei welcher Firma es ist, aber es wird tatsächlich einfach so angeboten, dass die Leute dem eine Liste der Telefonnummern schicken können. Und der haut dann einfach massenhaft diese SMS mal raus. Also es wird tatsächlich als Massen-SMS angeboten.
Das ist aber schon relativ teuer. Ich hab mich damals mal erkundigt, es gibt so Subunternehmen, die tatsächlich auch für den Operator eigenen Verkehr zuständig sind. Die sind diejenigen, die das mittlerweile auch immer noch machen. So was wie Dr. Materna und solche Sachen, also so ganz, ganz große Firmen, die tatsächlich dafür zuständig sind. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, dass der SMS-Verkehr unter den Operatoren, also E plus zu TD1 und so weiter, dass der überhaupt funktioniert. Dafür sind externe Firmen zuständig. Das machen die ja nicht selbst. Und diese Firmen haben natürlich, da die eher am Drücker sitzen, die Möglichkeit, diese fünfstelligen Nummern rauszuhauen, haben eh ihre Lines, da liegen wir, das ist ziemlich teuer, sich mit denen direkt zu verbinden. Das kostet aber auch eine Masse an Geld. Also diese SMS-Nummer ist nicht so billig wie Spam per E-Mail. Auf keinen Fall.
Die haben ihre Lines dann, aber anscheinend auch effektiver sogar noch.
Ja, aber da gibt es dann eben dieses, dieses Querfinanzierungsmodell, wo du durch die Teuer, also wenn du dann auf so eine Spam-SMS antwortest, dann verdient ja derjenige Geld. Derjenige, der dir die ursprüngliche Werbe-SMS geschickt bekommt hat. Und dadurch kriegen die halt wieder ihre Ausgaben rein.
Ich kriege immer solche SMS, wo drin steht, dass für mich ein Bett bereit steht. Ein leeres Bett allerdings, in einem Hotel. Denke ich mal, was soll ich da schlafen? Gut, am Telefon ist der Phil.
Nament. Ja, ich stehe hier schon, weil ich in der Warteschleife und...
Diebenzeit.
Und sie ist endlos lang.
Ja, genau.
Ja, und ich wollte einmal noch zum Thema SMS-Spam, dass ich kriege Ewigkeiten von irgendwelchen Videotheken SMS-Spam. Das Coole ist, ich bin in diese Videotheke reingegangen, hab gesagt, ja, sag mal Jungs, ich will keinen Spam mehr. Und dann meinten sie, hm, ja, sie können ja hier... Wir können probieren, sie aus der Findeliste runterzunehmen. Das haben sie schon dreimal probiert, also ich krieg sie immer noch. Ja, natürlich. Immerhin hab ich immer noch das bisschen genug tun, dass sie wahrscheinlich dafür irgendwie ein Zehntel Cent pro SMS zahlen. Naja, vielleicht bringt das was. Aber worum es mir eher ging, war das Thema E-Mail-Spam und weitere Lösungen. Es gibt seit einiger Zeit ein Verfahren namens StartLS. Das wird dafür benutzt, um Encryption auszuhandeln. Also wenn das E-Mails auch miteinander verschlüsselt reden können. Das benutzt leider kaum jemand.
Das bringt aber auch dich in puncto Spam nicht weiter.
Eventuell schon, indem man, also bei StartLS kann man sagen, dass es entforst ist, inwiefern Rechner nur miteinander verschlüsselt kommunizieren können.
Das hilft ja nichts, dann kriegst du sie verschlüsselt eingeliefert.
Und das Abhören könnte man dadurch, bzw. das Mitschneiden eventuell von...
Ja, das Mitschneiden kann man damit verhindern...
.minimal. Aber generell würde es dann in dem Prinzip Sinn machen, dass sich Provider einigen und sagen, ich möchte nur noch mit anderen Providern nur noch nach einem StartLS kommunizieren. Und auch in einer der berühmten DNS-Listen ablegen, okay, mails an mich, wenn es geht, nur per StartLS einzuliefern.
Da gibt es aber auch kein technisches Verfahren dafür. Also das StartLS und die Verschlüsselung selber bringt dir im puncto Spam-Verhinderung überhaupt gar nichts.
Wie gesagt, die Idee wär's gewesen, über eine DNS-Liste zu sagen, okay, diese Leute werden untereinander nur noch per StartLS kommunizieren. Könnte eventuell den Missbrauch ein bisschen einschränken, aber ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht messbar, das Ergebnis.
Das Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass Leute von anderen Hosts Mails verschicken können und behaupten können, sie wären irgendwie dieser und jener, und das wird akzeptiert. Und ich denke, dass dieser SPF-Ansatz, also das, was Harald Gröhn schon vorgestellt hat, dieses Sender Policy Framework an der Stelle eine echt gute Lösung sein kann.
Ich denke, die sind dem System durchaus kritisch gegenüber, weil es eventuell auch Leute gibt, wie zum Beispiel mich, die das tatsächlich benutzen, dass sie ihr Envelope From selbst setzen, um dann mit anderen Domains Mails rauszuschicken, als bei denen sie die Mails einliefern.
Das darfst du nach wie vor.
Ja, das ist bloß die Frage, ob ich denjenigen kriege, dem die E-Mail-Adresse gehört bzw. der Domain davon überzeugt kriege, meinen Provider dafür freizuschalten.
Ja gut, das ist aber, wie soll ich sagen, wenn du eine Domain von irgendjemanden anders benutzt, dann muss der dir ja erstmal einen E-Mail-Account irgendwie eintragen. Und dann muss er halt, wenn er dir einen E-Mail-Account einträgt, eben auch das in die DNS-Zone entsprechend eintragen, dass ein Server von dir dafür zuständig ist. Oder dir alternativ eben auch einen authentifizierten SMTP-Account für eingehende E-Mails einsichten, dass du dann die E-Mails, die von dieser Domain kommen, eben auch nur über ihn verschickst.
Also wenn er das nicht möchte, dass du das tust und es dir nicht erlaubt, dann bist du ja auch ein Spammer, wenn du das tust.
Nun, ich glaube vielmehr, dass es das große Problem gibt, dass viele Leute sagen, selbstverständlich habe ich kein Problem damit, wenn du das tust. Allerdings ist mir das viel zu aufwendig, dafür jetzt irgendeine Lösung zu schaffen. Und du bist einer von vielleicht 1000 Usern, die daran interessiert sind.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel bei SPF ist AOL da interessiert. Das ist nicht einer von 1000, sondern das sind Millionen von Usern, die dann schon mal irgendwie, dadurch, dass einfach ein einzelner großer Provider sowas einsetzt, abgedeckt.
Ja, Hotmail wird das auch machen und alle Großen werden das machen. Und deswegen ist das Hauptproblem damit auch schon mal echt erledigt. Und du kannst es auch schrittweise selber bei deiner eigenen Domain mit einführen und irgendwann dann auch zu übergehen, zu sagen, so ohne SPF nehme ich hier überhaupt nichts mehr an. Und dann übt man halt Druck aus. Das heißt, erst gibt es eine Übergangsphase, wo man das anbietet. So Leute, ich mach das jetzt auch. Ihr könnt das bei mir auch benutzen. Und irgendwann macht man dann selber die Tür zu und sagt, okay, ohne SPF läuft hier gar nichts mehr. Und dann kann das funktionieren.
Gut, das Problem, was ich mit SPF sah, ist z.B. mein Fall. Ich schreibe meine Unimails von meinem Rechner zu Hause aus, liefer die Mails bei meinem Provider ein und setze das Envelope-Form auf meine Uni-Adresse. Weil ich möchte z.B. dass ich damit mit der Adresse z.B. bestimmte Mailing-Discs gegenüber autorisiert bin oder auch bestimmte anderen Sachen. Für die Leute, die es ganz genau nachfrösten wollen, sind die Mails in Syso-PGP signiert. Aber die Uni wird mit Sicherheit mir sagen, sollte SPF eingeführt sein, was du benutzt, du benutzt das so und so. Du bist mit Sicherheit von unseren x-tausend Studenten einer von dreien, die das so benutzen werden. Dafür werden wir eine Lösung schaffen.
Aber du kannst doch den Uni-SMTP-Server benutzen.
Ja, das macht mein Mail-Setup wieder um Faktor 10 komplizierter.
Du brauchst nur für jede E-Mail-Adresse den dazugehörigen SMTP-Server konfigurieren. Das macht doch heute jedes ordentliche Mail-Programm.
Gut, meine Mat-AC wächst dann schon mal wieder um ein paar Kilobyte.
Also ich meine, mit den simple E-Mail-Clients geht das. Und wenn das irgendwie mit deinem Komplexen nicht geht, dann solltest du vielleicht darüber nachdenken, irgendwie Bunti-Kiki-Programme zu benutzen. Nein, ich meine, das ist ja nicht das Problem. Also ich meine, du machst ja schon den Eindruck, als ob du die grundsätzliche Architektur durchaus verstanden hast. Dann wird dir das ja wohl gelingen, in Abhängigkeit von einer Absende-E-Mail-Adresse auch einen entsprechenden SMTP-Server einzutragen, mit dem du die Mail versendest, weil das ist auch das, was man will.
Zum Empfangen musst du ja auch den entsprechenden Server eintragen.
Genau, damit es eben authentifiziert ist. Und genau da wollen wir ja hin. Und du hast ja auch ein Interesse daran, das zu unterstützen, eine solche Architektur, weil es hilft uns allen, diesen Scheiß spammlos zu werden. Also ich denke mal, das wird jetzt auch die letzte Chaosradio-Sendung zu diesem Thema Spam gewesen sein, weil das einfach mal nicht zehn Jahre dauern wird, weil der Hass ist einfach bei allen schon sehr groß. Und der Druck auf den Providern ist eben nicht nur die Unzufriedenheit der Kunden, sondern auch einfach die Kostenlast, die auf ihn draufliegen.
Ich meine, du weißt doch ganz genau, wie lange das gebraucht hat, bis die Musikindustrie es immer noch nicht geschafft hat, einen ordentlichen Download-Service auf die Beine zu stellen. Und da mussten die Geld mit verdienen.
Aber die Musikindustrie ist jetzt einfach... Die Provider sind ja alle viel schlau. Wir haben jetzt auch eine Marketing-Abteilung und ihr Wissen über Internet unterhalten. Also ich denke, die haben einfach keine Ahnung, aber Internet-Service-Provider sind ein bisschen schlauer. Also wenn die keine Ahnung haben, dann können wir das Internet auch gleich zumachen.
Guckt euch an, die Spam-Geschichte, wann gingen sie los, sagen wir mal, 1998 kommt hin, oder? Die ersten Ansätze waren dann unter anderem, dass Leute anfingen mit dem schon früher erwähnten Tear-Grooving, Spam unattraktiv zu machen. Das war damals die Hoffnung, das Problem mit dem Spam auch bei einigen Leuten in den Griff zu bekommen.
Nee, das war eine Hoffnung. Der erste Ansatz war, Open Relays zuzumachen und dann eben noch die restlichen offenen Relays zu blacklisten in entsprechenden Zonefiles. Und das funktioniert ja auch ganz gut.
Ja, das funktionierte so lange gut, bis die Spammer entdeckt haben, dass man HTTP-Server und alle möglichen anderen Möglichkeiten auch noch mal ausnutzen kann, um dann doch authenticated in die Netze von Providern hinein doch wieder Mails zu schicken.
Aber gegen die wird ja mittlerweile auch per Blacklisting vorgegangen. Ich bin da auch schon mal reingeraten.
Ja, das Problem ist halt, dass ich persönlich eure Hoffnung nicht teile und sage, na ja, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, aber wir leben jetzt in der totalen Wildwestwelt. Jeder Fazke kann sich jetzt einen Perl-Script zusammenbatzgen und über den erstbesten Mailserver einfach Spam an beliebig viele Leute rausschicken. Das geht dann halt mit SPF erstmal nicht so, sondern wenn du es tust, dann tust du es auf jeden Fall über einen Host, wo diejenigen, wenn du auch noch Authentifizierung benutzen musst, so ziemlich genau wissen, wer du bist. Und in dem Moment, wo dann halt die Spam als solche berichtet wird, dann kriegt man dich zumindest schon mal schnell an Kadi. Und in dem Moment, wo es auch noch eine brauchbare Spam-Gesetzgebung gibt und ich denke, die ist am Anrollen, hast du ein Problem. Und in dem Moment rechnet sich natürlich das nicht mehr, weil dich kosten eine Million E-Mails unter Umständen echt eine Menge Geld, weil du eben für jede E-Mail 1000 Euro zahlen darfst, Strafe.
Und vor allem der Peer-Pressure sozusagen unter den Providern wird ja auch entsprechend groß.
Genau.
Das heißt, die zeigen dann alle irgendwann mit dem Finger auf deinen Provider und dein Provider wird dann sagen, ne, machen wir nicht mehr.
Da gibt es auch schon erste Signale von Providern, die einfach sagen, wir haben jetzt einfach mal die Schnauze voll und wenn ihr jetzt weiter schickt hier mit euren dicken Bike-E-Mails, dann machen wir euch einfach weg. Dann löschen wir einfach die Rauten zu euch und dann seid ihr einfach nicht mehr im Internet. Und das ist zwar eine krasse Maßnahme, aber in dem Moment, wo damit gedroht wird und das ist eigentlich das Schlimmste, womit man drohen kann auf Provider-Ebene, auf Internet-Ebene, wird sich auch was bewegen.
Phil, danke dir erstmal für den Anruf. Ich wollte noch kurz was vorlesen, bevor wir in die Nachrichten gehen. Und zwar hat der Robert uns ja versprochen nachzugucken, ob er dieses Recruiting-Schreiben findet von den Typen, die selber Spam versenden. Das hat er jetzt getan. Und ich kann ja mal kurz einen Auszug vorlesen. Es ist leider nicht mehr das Originaldokument, aber es geht in der Newsgroup um das Thema und da wurden teilweise die Sachen zitiert. Wir suchen keinen SUSE Red Hat-Zertifizierten Samba-Server-Admin und keinen Umschüler, sondern jemanden, der Admin geworden ist, nicht weil er es zum Coder nicht gereicht hat, sondern weil er Admin werden wollte und ihn das administrieren und die Systemplanung von großen Rechnernetzen Spaß macht. Als Kenntnisse bringen sie zum einen detaillierte Kenntnisse aus dem E-Mail-Bereich mit und wissen auch, wie zum Beispiel Eingangsfilter bei bekannten Providern funktionieren.
So, das ist jetzt normal.
Jetzt kommt die lustige. Sekunde.
Also arbeitslose Systemat-Illustratorin, auf die diese Bezeichnung, diese Beschreibung passt, gibt es ja eine Menge.
Also Aufgaben, anderes Rekrutierungsschreiben. Du musst dich sehr gut mit Unix, Linux auskennen, das heißt eins unter Gott. Du musst dich sehr gut mit Netztechnologien auskennen, auch wieder eins unter Gott. Schön wäre auch, wenn du grundlegende Exploit-Techniken kennst und LEDs, N-Map, weißer Teufel, es kommen irgendwie 1500 Sachen, die ich natürlich wahrscheinlich wieder falsch aussprechen würde. Alte Bekannte für dich sind ohne dies, was, was, was, ohne das du danach googelst, ist klar. Wir sind kein Laber- und Marketing-Schuppen und auch kein Konsulter. Wir sind sehr flexibel und hassen normal. Wir bieten keinen 8-Stunden-Tag mit geregelten Arbeitszeiten und auch keine Ausbildung zum NT-Print-Server admin.
Sehr witzig.
Steht nur drunter als Kommentar, klingt irgendwie sympathisch. Ehrlich, gut, wir machen Nachrichten, Leute.
Wenn Fritz immer zahm, dann 102, 6.
Fritz Info.
Wir haben es 0 auf 34. Das Wetter, nachts ist es relativ kalt und klar. Vielleicht habt ihr mal rausgeschaut, es ist dunkel, richtig, zwischen 5 und 1 Grad. Am Tag ist es meist heiter, ab und zu so ein paar Wölkchen, ist aber irrelevant. Vor der Sonne, die Temperaturen steigen auf 16 Grad.
UN-Generalsekretär Anan hält in seinem Zypernplan fest. Am 24. April sollen die griechische und türkische Bevölkerungsgruppe über die Wiedervereinigung abstimmen. Falls eine Seite den Plan ablehnt, wird am 1. Mai nur der griechische Teil Zyperns der EU beitreten. Anan hat bis spät in die Nacht mit den Konfliktparteien verhandelt. Afghanistan erhält in den nächsten 3 Jahren mehr als 8 Milliarden Dollar an internationaler Hilfe. Das teilte Finanzminister Ghani am späten Abend auf der Geberkonferenz in Berlin mit. Nach den Worten von Präsident Karzai wird das Geld zum Wiederaufbau und zum Kampf gegen den Drogenanbau dringend benötigt. Sein Land ist der größte Opiumproduzent der Welt. Im Mannesmann-Prozess können die Angeklagten nach dem bisherigen Stand der Beweisaufnahme mit Freisprüchen rechnen. Das sagte die Vorsitzende Richterin. Es gebe keine Anhaltspunkte für Untreue gegenüber der Mannesmann AG. Zum Sport, die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft der Männer hat in Köln gegen Belgien 3 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Frauen-Nationalmannschaft schlug Italien mit 1 zu 0. Albert Bedin verteidigte die Spitze der Basketball-Bundesliga mit einem 86 zu 76 in Ludwigsbrücken. Der Verkehr auf Fritz, wir haben keine Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Für ein richtig gutes Radiokonzert braucht man richtig gute Musik.
The Streets, das exklusive Radiokonzert im Kolumbier Fritz-Belli. The Streets, das exklusive Radiokonzert. Nur für euch und nur auf Fritz. Ab 20 Uhr live und direkt aus dem Kolumbier Fritz-Berlin und im Radio.
Wunderschöne Musik, die Tim mitgebracht hat. Ich bin die Warteschleife. Was uns zum Thema heute Abend bringt, es ist übrigens das Chaos Radio, was ihr hört, auf Fritz mit Tim, Frank, Harald und Max, meiner Person zum Thema Telefon-Spam. Haben wir heute Abend noch nicht drüber gesprochen.
Die ist auch nicht wirklich unser Thema, aber es wurde uns von einem Hörer berichtet, dass er mittlerweile auch schon per Telefon belästigt wird. Also nicht nur irgendwie lästige Mails irgendwie über Viagra und Penisverlängerungen im E-Mail-Postfach, sondern auch schon am Telefon. Man ruft dann also so ein Telefoncomputer an, guten Tag, wir möchten Sie über die neuesten Produkte der Firma XY informieren. Wenn Sie mehr wissen wollen, drücken Sie bitte die 1. Oder so ähnlich. Also schon ziemlich lästig. Also weil, als ich in so einem Telefonanruf irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich, so im Zeitalter von irgendwie E-Mail und SMS so telefonieren, tue ich halt eher weniger und ich finde halt so ein Telefonanruf, fände ich halt irgendwie noch viel extremer in meine Privatsphäre eingreifend als jetzt irgendwie, das ist ein bisschen laut, in meine Privatsphäre eingreifend als irgendwie so eine E-Mail, die mir jetzt irgendwelchen Quatsch anbietet. Also das ist nochmal so ein ganz erheblicher Faktor. Das wäre irgendwie wie ein persönlich an mich adressierter Brief, so den ich hier aufmache.
Ich hatte neulich übrigens die, eine Dame von Infratez, die Telefon, die mit mir eine politische Umfrage machen wollte. Das war natürlich sehr spannend.
Du stehst im Telefonbuch, ja?
Ne, ich stehe nämlich nicht im Telefonbuch.
Wie?
Ich stehe nicht im Telefonbuch, bin nicht gelistet. Ich weiß nicht, worauf die dann zurückgreifen. Ich wollte sie nicht vergraulen, sie war auch sehr nett. Ich meinte dann politische Umfrage, um welches Thema geht es? Politik in Berlin, ich sage, warum denn genau und so weiter. Weil ich habe nicht so viel Zeit, ich würde es nur machen, wenn es spannend ist. Wer hat denn die Umfrage in Auftrag gegeben? Das darf ich ihnen leider nicht sagen. Und das sagt man mir auch gar nicht, damit ich es gar nicht sagen kann. Da habe ich gesagt, nee, dann nicht. Finde ich langweilig. Okay, nee, kein Problem. Danke, tschüss. Und dann war sie wieder weg. Also sie war sehr freundlich, aber ich finde es auch immer schön, mal so gegen zu heulchen. Einfach Gegenfragen zu stellen, weil das Recht hat man schließlich. Hat man selber so ein bisschen seinen Spaß dran.
Ja, naja, aber ich stimme dem Frank schon zu mit dem Kritikpunkt, dass ein Telefonanruf, das ist was, was mich da genau unterbricht, was ich gerade tue, da kommt dieser Anruf und ich muss mich jetzt genau darum kümmern. Hingegen bei E-Mails, die kann ich halt irgendwann lesen, wenn es mir gerade passt. Und wenn da Spam dabei ist, dann kann ich den halt da ausfiltern. Aber so ein Telefonanruf, der ist halt potenziell immer sehr viel unpassender, weil er eben in Echtzeit erfolgt.
Ich muss allerdings sagen, mit Spam irgendwann lesen ist gut. Also wenn du hier irgendwie eine Woche nicht da warst, kommst du zurück, hast 1100 Mails, da bleiben nach dem Filter erfolgreich dann noch 600 Stück übrig, da musst du dir die Scheiße durchlesen. Da fragen dann irgendwie die Leute, wenn du dich hinsetzt, dann sagt irgendjemand zu dir, sag mal, du liest Mails, das ist doch jetzt hier deine Arbeitszeit. Wo ich so denke, ja klar, aber glaubst du, das ist Spaß, was ich hier mache oder was? Da bekomm ich doch nicht früher. Weil das ist halt nur Arbeit, das ist nur noch Arbeit. Das hat nichts mehr mit Fun zu tun.
Wir sollten ein bisschen dieses sagenumwobene SPF noch ein bisschen erklären. Wo uns auch jemand über uns darauf hingewiesen hat, dass wir das noch nicht haben. Nee, es liegt einfach daran, dass wir das sozusagen quasi auf dem Weg gerade mal irgendwie entdeckt haben als mögliche Lösung für das Spam-Problem. Oder vielleicht nicht Lösung, aber um es zumindest erst mal deutlich einzudämmen. Und wir haben zwar jetzt ziemlich viel drum rum geredet und irgendwie, wir sollten es einfach nochmal erklären.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal vorab, dass also SPF bei Weitem nicht der einzige Ansatz ist, der in die gleiche Richtung geht. Ich hatte das anfangs schon mal erwähnt, dass es also eine Reihe von Projekten gibt, die immer das gleiche Ziel verfolgen. Eben in irgendeiner Art und Weise zu überprüfen, ob die Absenderadresse, die in dieser E-Mail drin steht, auch tatsächlich irgendwie legitim zu dem Rechner gehört, wo sie herkam. Oder beziehungsweise der Rechner, der sie abgeschickt hat, auch legitimerweise diese E-Mail-Adresse verwenden darf. Wie man dann genau diese Information hinterlegt und wo man die hinterlegt, das ist dann das, was variiert zwischen den unterschiedlichen Verfahren. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht der wichtige Punkt bei der Sache. Wenn ich also eine E-Mail verschicke, dann schickt sie mein Mailprogramm an den E-Mail-Server meines Providers. Und dieser E-Mail-Server, der wird dann das Domain-Name-System befragen nach einem sogenannten MX-Rekord. Das ist ein Mailer Exchange-Rekord. Und dieser Rekord, der sagt aus, welcher Server im Internet kontaktiert werden soll für den Empfänger, den ich in meine E-Mail-Adresse angegeben habe. Und dann wird also dieser Mail-Server Kontakt aufnehmen zu dem Mail-Server, der in diesem MX-Rekord drin steht. Und dann die Mail dorthin zustellen an diesen Server, der dort eingetragen ist. Wenn die Empfangsadresse gültig ist, dann nimmt dieser Ziel Server die E-Mail auch an und die wird dann eben in das Postfach des Empfängers zugestellt. Das ist also das Verfahren, wie E-Mail üblicherweise heutzutage im Internet funktioniert. Und die Idee bei SPF und den ähnlichen Verfahren ist eben, da noch einen weiteren Schritt einzubauen, dass das nicht alles so in eine Richtung geht, sondern dass da eine Rückfrage kommt. Und zwar ist das so, in dem Moment, wo die E-Mail dann ausgeliefert wird, von dem Server meines Providers zum E-Mail Server des Providers des Empfängers, dann fragt dieser Empfänger in irgendeiner Datenbank und praktischerweise nimmt man da auch wieder dieses Domain-Namesystem her, fragt an, ob der Server, von dem diese E-Mail kommt, auch tatsächlich autorisiert ist, E-Mails zu versenden mit dieser Absenderadresse. Und damit das natürlich abgefragt werden kann, muss der Administrator von so einer Domain oder der Eigentümer oder wer auch immer, so einen Eintrag generieren im DNS-System oder in der entsprechenden Datenbank, wo drin steht, welche Server alle überhaupt E-Mails versenden dürfen für die Domain. Und das ist eigentlich die Idee, die dahinter steckt. Also diese ursprüngliche Idee, die kam, muss man dazu sagen, im Jahr 2002 von Vince Cerf. Das ist einer der Erfinder des Domain-Names-Systems, einer der Urväter des Internet. Alter Mann, grauhaarig, schon fast glatze. Und der hatte eben diesen Einfall und mittlerweile sind da eben ein paar Projekte daraus entstanden. SPF ist eines davon wohl das mit bekannteste. Wer sich da näher darüber informieren will, das ist spf.pobox.com, spf.pobox.com. Da kann man sich eben über SPF informieren. Da stehen dann auch die technischen Details dazu drin, wie diese Einträge in der DNS-Zone genau aussehen müssen. Und es ist sogar ein wunderschöner Clicky-Bunti-Generator dabei. Also man kann einfach alles, seine Daten ausfüllen in einem Web-Formular und dann wird dieser Eintrag generiert. Dann muss man diesen Eintrag, der dann letztendlich generiert wird, nur noch in diese DNS-Zone hineinbringen. Das geht natürlich ganz leicht, wenn man seinen eigenen Server hat oder seine eigenen DNS-Zone-Files konfigurieren kann. Wenn man das nicht kann, dann muss man diesen Einsatz natürlich irgendwie seinem Provider schicken, damit der dort eben entsprechend in die DNS-Zone eingetragen wird.
Na dann viel Spaß. Vor allen Dingen, geben wir das erstmal erklären, obwohl die dürften so langsam davon wissen, dass es das gibt, oder?
Es kommt drauf an, also es kommt sehr drauf an, wo man da ist. Also wenn man jetzt wirklich bei einem Provider ist, wo die Leute Ahnung haben, dann sollte das kein Problem sein. Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwo bei, keine Ahnung, also ich möchte jetzt keine Namen nennen, um da jetzt nicht übelne Rache zu reden oder sonst irgendwas. Aber ja, wenn ich bei einem Provider bin, wo derjenige, mit dem ich dann, der mein Ansprechpartner ist, der, der, wenn derjenige was versteht von der Thematik, dann wird er das auch kennen. Also wenn ich in irgendeinem Calling Center lande, dann ja, dann ist natürlich aussichtslos.
Übrigens eine ganz spannende Geschichte, die Obi hier bei uns ins Board geschrieben hat. Was man doch auch machen könnte, da müsste man mal darüber diskutieren, ist natürlich auch nicht ganz wasserdicht das Ding, aber er hat geschrieben, was wäre, wenn Provider einfach die Mails checken würden und Mails, die massenhaft kommen. Also wo klar ist, dass die irgendwie am Stück, meinetwegen nach alphabetischem Muster, alphabetischem Vornamenmuster, wo gesucht worden ist, beim Provider oder wenn die Dinge an bestimmte Adressen gehen, die nicht existieren, sagen wir es mal so. Wenn mehr als zehn davon angesprochen werden, dass dann die Teile einfach sofort weggesendet werden und nicht mehr an diejenigen, die sie weiterhin bekommen sollen, ist das nicht möglich? Wenn du dann guckst, dass du dann eben die Einschlägigen, die oft gewählten, was weiß ich, Mailinglisten oder so durchlässt.
Ja, aber das ist dann wieder der Waffengang, von dem Harald schon ein paar Mal geredet hat. Erstmal fügt das natürlich eine extreme Komplexität in dein Mail-Setup rein, mit der hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass durch diese Maßnahmen, die du versuchst, in deinen Code reinzubringen, so viele Fehler in dein System reinbringen.
Oder auch Sicherheitslücken möglicherweise.
Und dann wiederum auch andere Sicherheitslücken, die komplett in die andere Richtung gehen. Und auf der anderen Seite kann man überhaupt nicht davon ausgehen, dass es auch immer auf diese Art und Weise stattfindet. Das ist vielleicht dann heute so und morgen auch noch. Aber nächste Woche bemerken die Spammer das. Und dann verteilen sie es halt anders und senden es mal dahin und mal dahin. Das machen sie wahrscheinlich jetzt auch schon, um nicht aufzufallen.
Mehrere Punkte. Also diesen Mechanismus, den verwendet man vor allem im Usenet. Im Usenet verwendet man den Mechanismus. Clean Feed wird dort verwendet, die Software. Und da ist es eben auch so, dass man quasi einen Hash, in dem Fall ist es ein MD5-Hash, über den Artikel macht. Also Artikel ist das, was eine E-Mail entspricht im Usenet. Das ist also eine Prüf-Summe. Und wenn ich so und so viel, da gibt es dann so einen Schwellwert, also wenn ich mal 10, 50, 100, 150 Artikel bekommen habe, die die gleiche Prüf-Summe ergeben, dann weiß ich, dass da einfach der gleiche Inhalt drin war in dieser E-Mail. Und dann nehme ich einfach keine, in diesem Artikel, und dann nehme ich einfach keine weiteren solchen Artikel mehr an.
Funktioniert aber auch nicht, weil die Mails mittlerweile auch alle individuell sind.
Richtig, genau, das ist der Punkt. Ja, das wollte ich jetzt auch gerade beschreiben. Das war wieder dieses Wettrüsten. Man hat das angefangen einzuführen, und dann sind die Spammer eben draufgekommen, oh, da gibt's sowas. Also müssen wir in jede E-Mail unten irgendwo eine zufällige Zeichenfolge oder irgendwas reinmachen, damit eben diese Prüfsumme nicht mehr eindeutig ist. Und das große Problem, das man eben hat, wenn man das bei E-Mails einführen würde, ist, dass man eben diese ganzen Mailing-Listen damit auch ausschalten würde. Und du kannst nie irgendwo ein vollständiges Verzeichnis sämtlicher Newsletter und Mailing-Listen erstellen. Also das ist witzlos. Da gibt es alleine im freien Software-Bereich sicherlich einige Zehntausend, wenn es reicht. Und das ändert sich ständig. Und jeder, der irgendwo Zugriff auf den Server hat, kann eine Mailing-Liste aufmachen. Und das soll er auch dürfen und können. Und das ist eine tolle Funktion.
Lass uns zum Schluss noch den Daniel dran nehmen und den Roland gleich. Daniel, bist du noch da? Na, sorry, fürs lange Warten, weil wir haben noch ungefähr zehn Minuten und ihr sollt auch noch zu Wort kommen heute Abend.
Ja, mir ging's eigentlich darum, was spricht eigentlich gegen Blacklisten bei großen Mail-Provider?
Was willst du den Blacklisten genau? Was soll da drinstehen?
Na, ich mein, zum Beispiel ich bin ja auch bei einem der größten deutschen Lieben Provider, ich weiß nicht, ich sag's einfach, Webtee ist halt der größte bei uns hier. Und der hat meiner Meinung nach einen relativ guten Spam-Filter drin, so wie ich das bemerkt habe. Ich verfolge das ja auch ständig. Und eigentlich bei mir sind noch die Mails weggekommen, die ich hätte haben wollen.
Weißt du das?
Ja klar, weil da gibt es doch dieses System mit diesen drei Kategorien. Einmal die eine, wo ich sagen muss, das sind wirklich Mails für mich. Die ist von Anfang an erstmal gesperrt. Da muss ich erst Leute eintragen. Denn die eine Kategorie, die ist unsicher, da weiß der Filter nicht so genau, sind es nur böse oder sind es gute Mails. Und dann gibt es die letzte Kategorie, die ist ja dann so eingerichtet, da kommen dann wirklich Mails rein, die eindeutig als Spam erkannt wurden. Und da habe ich bisher wirklich noch keine Eins hier.
Na das kannst du gar nicht wissen. Bist du zum Beispiel auf unserem Chaosradio-Ticker, auf der Ankündigungsliste für die neue Sendung? Wärst du da drauf gewesen? Hättest du unter Umständen? Ja, in dem Fall war es GMX, aber wer sagt dir, dass es bei WebDE nicht genauso ist? Letzten Endes benutzen die auch alle in etwa die gleichen Strategien und gucken beieinander ab. Ich könnte jetzt auch behaupten, ich hätte dir eine Mail geschickt, meine habe ich jetzt nicht, aber so, weißt du, und dann weißt du davon nichts.
Selbstmöglich, aber ich sage es deswegen, weil ich schaue mir auch diesen Ordner auch trotzdem an, bevor ich den lösche.
Das kannst du eben noch.
Wenn ich mir das angucke, bei mir, ich habe es vorhin mal überschlagen, also 800 bis 1500 Spam-Mails am Tag sind gar nichts. Will ich die tatsächlich noch durchgucken?
Ja, okay, das ist richtig. So viel habe ich noch nicht, aber ich sage mal pro Tag, an die 100 sind auch schon drin.
Die liest du doch nicht alle durch.
Nein, nur vom Betreff her, auch nur grob, okay, das gebe ich zu.
Ja, aber den brauchst du auch nicht zu fettern.
Wenn der Betreff Hallo ist, was machst du?
Aber den kannst du auch gleich in der Inbox lassen und dann einfach löschen.
Und da sind unter Umständen auch schon viele Mails nicht mehr dabei, die schon gar nicht mehr den Weg zu dir gefunden haben, weil sie als so hundertprozentig rausgefiltert worden sind, dass sie gleich abgelehnt wurden. Das waren dann vielleicht auch Spams, aber es gibt da halt einfach keine Sicherheit. Das ist das Problem. Und diese ganze Filtermethodik, das mag jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen helfen, aber lösen tut es das Problem auf keinen Fall.
Das hilft im Übrigen auch nur, das ist nicht so, dass das so eine einfache Geschichte ist, sondern das hilft in dem Fall bei Web.de nur, weil da mit Sicherheit mehrere Leute, bis nicht eine ganze Abteilung, nichts anderes tut, als diese Filter zu pflegen und ständig aktuell zu halten. Und das ist also, wenn du jetzt bei jedem Provider so und so viele Leute hinsetzen musst, die solche Filter pflegen, und dann aber immer noch keine Gewissheit hast, und es ist alles leider nicht wasserdicht.
Stimmt, aber warum würde denn, da wäre doch der andere Weg auch nicht schlecht. Du kannst ja, also ich kann ja, wenn ich per Webinterface drin bin, ist natürlich auch bloß bei einem Meringue-Mail darauf kommen machbar, aber wenn ich per Webinterface drin bin, kann ich ja auch sagen, okay, die Mails sind definitiv Spam. Und die wandern dann weg. Warum können solche Listen denn nicht irgendwie zentral verwaltet werden? Und wenn es mehrere machen, sind es halt auch eindeutig Spam-Mails.
Und dann gibt es irgendwelche Leute, die Spaß daran haben, gültige E-Mails damit wegzuklicken. Also ich meine, möchtest du jemanden anders anvertrauen zu entscheiden, welche E-Mail gültig ist und welche nicht? Wem vertraust du da dabei? Das ist alles wieder eine schwierige Frage.
Und ganz kurz gleich noch eine zweite Frage, die ist mir vorhin aufgefallen, als ihr das gesagt hattet, dass von Spamern mittlerweile auch diese ganzen Sommer und Trojaner benutzt werden, dass auf Windows-Seiten kleine Mail-Server installiert werden.
Ist denn das Potenzial da so groß?
Also ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Anscheinend. Die Masse macht es.
Wie kann man denn ein richtiges Programm installieren, ohne dass der Mensch was dazu tut? Ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass er einen Anhang einer Mail anklickt.
Also das Schöne ist ja bei einigen Microsoft-Programmen, dass er ja nicht mehr was tun muss, sondern...
Ja, man muss nicht mal klicken und das geht schon.
Ich meine, Outlook muss man nicht benutzen, das ist richtig.
Ja, aber die Leute tun es.
Ja, das ist richtig. Da gab es jetzt kürzlich, habe ich bei einem Bekannten gesehen, er war auf einer Webseite mit einem Explorer, die wurde kurz zu laden, wurde danach gleich geschlossen und in diesem Moment hat sich ein Programm selber gestartet.
Das ist Standard, Daniel, fast schon, leider Gottes. Am besten hau dir eine Firewall rein, die das alles beobachtet und jeden Programm startet irgendwie.
Er hat ja eine am Laufen, das ist ja ein Problem.
Das hilft alles nichts, das ist halt das Problem. Software ist einfach buggy und leider ist die Software, die am weitesten verbreitet ist, sogar ziemlich buggy. Ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht in dieses allgemeine Windows-Bashing mich mit einreihen, aber diese Monokultur hat das natürlich extrem gefördert.
Und solange die User auf alles klicken, was irgendwie auf dem Bildschirm ist, dann...
Ja, und es ist sogar verständlich.
Solange es Hersteller gibt, die aberwitzige Mechanismen in den E-Mail-Reader einbauen, was muss ein E-Mail-Reader überhaupt die Funktion haben, irgendwo Gramm aufzurufen? Find ich überflüssig.
Daniel, dank dir für den Anruf, wir müssen den Roland noch kurz wahrnehmen, okay? Roland, bist du noch da?
Ja, ich bin noch da.
Jo, auf die Kurz, wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit.
Ich hab eine normale T-Online-Adresse und ein kleines Betrieb, ein kleines Fotoarchiv. Viele Sachen werden per Mail gemacht. Ich besuch Amazon und bestell mir auch schon mal was im Internet, was dann geliefert wird. Aber ich bekomm keine Spams.
Hast du denn deine E-Mail-Adresse auf einer Webseite irgendwo drauf?
Ja, die ist auf einer Webseite drauf.
Wie lang hast du die schon?
Wie bitte?
Wie lang hast du die E-Mail-Adresse schon?
Also ich hab eine Mail-Adresse schon sehr lange gehabt, das ist eine alte Compost Surf Adresse, die hab ich bis vor einem Jahr gehabt. Dann hab ich sie gewechselt und bin jetzt bei T-Online.
Also seit einem Jahr hast du die T-Online-Adresse und hast noch keine Spams bekommen?
Ja, und bei Compost Surf war ohne Ende Spam und seit dem T-Online ist nichts mehr.
Dann würd ich sagen, du bist der Gewinner des Abends.
Du bist unser Golem heute Abend. Roland, der Zukunfts-Golem. Da wollen wir hinarbeiten, wo du bist. Vielen Dank für den Anruf. So, das war's mit dem Chaosradio heute Abend. Wenn ihr noch irgendwelche Meldungen habt, irgendwie abgesungen lassen wollt, dann macht das einfach per Mail.
Genau, 90abchaosradio.ccc.de Genau, vielen, vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen.
Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Sehr fruchtbar, sehr erfolgreich. Wir haben natürlich jetzt nicht die ultimative Lösung geliefert, aber hoffentlich einen Denkanstoß.
Aber wir haben zumindest alle blöden Varianten, alle Nicht-Lösungen sozusagen auch mal auseinandergelegt.
Wir würden uns auch auf Feedback freuen von Leuten, die SPF schon verwenden.
Genau.
Das kommt uns leider nicht per Anrufer, aber wenn es da sowas schon gibt, dann schickt uns spam.
Danke auch die Community, die im Board mitgemacht hat und nicht telefonisch auf fritz.de. Wir verabschieden uns und jetzt nennet ihr eure Namen alle mal selber. Ich sehe gar nicht ein, dass ich das immer selber machen muss. Im Uhrzeigersinn melden wir uns.
Frank, Harald, Tim und Max.
Vielen, vielen Dank. Jetzt kommt der Petersdorf und macht einen schönen Night Flight mit viel Musik. Macht's gut.